welcome to park gym 3 presented by grip6 and a
huge welcome to my new co-host miss andrea bottas
and welcome to your version i'm so excited i'm
so excited it's my first time commentating and
i'm really happy to be doing it with anna today
what was it meant to be it was meant to be i just
hope that the same thing will not happen when
i had cutest cinderella as my dream co-host and
then my power went out so cross fingers that
just because we have girl squad and i'm with
the one and only andrea bottas we will manage
to handle the show power-wise all right let's
let's hope let's hope you also have issues i have
a good charm for technology where when i'm around
nothing will break and everything will work
perfectly for the entire day i promise it's
good to know since both you and alex had to
take a few days off of streaming because of
the weather conditions in texas we're
happy to see that now things are better
and that you are safe ready to do the commentary
today let's take a look at the format on what's
going on now with the championship bracket so
this is the very first day of the championship
and consolation bracket the knockout stage
meaning that the players will be playing
in an eliminatory system the winner will move
on to the next stage to the semifinals and the
loser of today's matches will have to say
goodbye to the tournament they are playing
one game each one game with the white pieces one
game with the black pieces and in case of a tie
after the two games we're gonna go and see a
sudden death blitz game five minutes no increment
and you look at also this next slide with the
big cache lots of money at stake and many of
many of the prices by the participants
have been already offered for charity
we do have a charity initiative for park
gym 3 as well as the participants themselves
offering their entire price fund for charity
many of them have already said it on their
streams which is i think a wonderful suggestion
that's very sweet the stakes are very high today
anyone who loses is out it's gonna be lots
of pressure on them exactly anyone who loses
today will take home four thousand dollars
if they move on to the semi-finals that's
at least six thousand or more as we can see
the winner in the championship bracket will
take home 20 000 either for themselves or for
their charity speaking of charity again we do
have our community outreach and we hope to reach
25 000 today if we could show again our bar and
where are we at the moment with the viewer charity
donations so far we have raised over 17 000
thanks to each and every one of you for your
donations chess.com will be matching every
single penny so make sure to make them pay as much
as possible they're gonna read they're gonna match
every single donation up to a hundred thousand
dollars so click on the link in the banner
in the chat you'll see a charity link that's where
you can donate and every single penny matters
i think we also have our bracket beautifully
presented now on what happened after the group
stage today we will be starting with two matches
in the championship bracket the first one being
between the winner of group b xqc and the second
place player of group a sardoche after which we'll
move on to the left side of the bracket benji
fishy the winner of group a will be taking on
group b's second place player daniel negrano
so those are the two matches for today the
starting times are as shown here 120 pacific for
the first match between xqc and sardoche and the
second match benji fishy versus daniel negranu at
approximately 2 40 pacific tomorrow though andrea
tomorrow is gonna be an even bigger day with four
matches what are your thoughts on the pairings
for tomorrow honestly all these i mean all these
participants have been playing so well i mean even
for today the games are so close i have no idea
but rain has been a monster i think nico has a
really great chance in the consolation pokemon for
smith i'm so excited to see you we've coached them
both and i know you've also done a few coaching
with the participants what do you think is going
to be the most exciting match for tomorrow i think
i'm going to be after hosting a watch party of
my own i'm not doing the show tomorrow but three
of my students are playing so i'm gonna be there
biting my nails for sure nico versus rubios
is a case where i have i have given lessons
to both of them i'm gonna do the same i really
want to do a watch party these gay you're just
so emotionally invested when you've coached them
it's hard man it's really hard it's really hard
and before we get to today's matches and what's
coming up let's also thank our sponsor kwayaki
who are celebrating 25 years of regenerative year
by mate and they are sharing cases to celebrate
with you guys all you need to do is to spam the
goyaki emote in the chat for a chance to win
and we will be back after a short break the
regeneration of the planet is integrated into
our business model purchases of guayaqui yerba
mate support stewardship of the south american
atlantic rainforest and the self-sufficiency of
indigenous communities these purchases advance
a carbon-balanced renewable energy economy
and provide meaningful employment for the
formerly incarcerated guayaqui's sales also fuel
communities and activists driving the regenerative
movement meanwhile your enjoyment of yerba
mate reconnects you with the vitality of life
when we come to life we care about one another
and stand together to create a better future
right and basically like if you do something
like this you can already play it push push punch
and just try try to attack because he's pushed
the pawns in front of his king too much here
basically this is a basic setup that i think
is very simple if he does this i don't think
he will do this but he might do this um so let's
let's take a look at the other setup he might do
which is he might push his pawn here yeah i
usually match with the pawn here right okay
so you can match with pawn yeah he's gonna move
his bishop here i would normally just go for uh
attacking the pawn here like this okay so this
is completely fine and now he's gonna probably
push his pawn forward uh like this okay um i can't
want to castle and since i'm developing right side
sometimes i push uh sometimes i do this right
so this is this is fine what i actually would
say just to keep it really simple is again push
this pawn okay and have the theme yeah go ahead
and have the same idea as against the
other opening setup which is actually
when white moves like the knight here
just move the bishop to the center okay
and let's say white trades the bishops here for
example white takes you take with the queen yeah
and all this whole opening it it's all around this
one square this is literally the only thing that
matters like if you don't blender pieces it's all
about the square so like when you move your bishop
here you want to try to push your pawn because
then you open up this diagonal for your bishop
okay yeah yeah so let's say white trades you
can take and then when white moves the bishop
for example you can just push this pawn and you
take the the middle part of the floor yes yes
yes yes yes yeah it uh it's something i started
doing like that um it's actually pushing the pawn
next to the other one and then uh you oh oh sorry
uh go back yeah that's fine and then you trade it
yeah uh i've been having a problem with it it's
sometimes when i when i pawn block out mid and i
can't open up both my bishops and they're like
stack bugged totally so this is probably what
i would say is you basically when this happens
you just want to push so let's just say white
castles just to give a basic basic idea you push
e5 yeah if white doesn't take you're going to fork
yeah for sure so let's say white takes and white
trades it all all down you have to push upon yeah
and now you just move your knight say castle and
you just castle and the idea is you want to move
your bishop here and put both your rooks in the
center of the board okay on these two squares and
then you can just play in the middle game oh yeah
this is the idea okay let me give you scenario
this one happens very often uh bishop bishop
g4 oh okay sorry in the in his current position
yeah fifty-four okay like white's move okay so
bishop g4 okay yeah and then uh let's say he
does a pawn pawn f3 well if he does it here you
can just take and you actually kind of win win
the game oh yeah i knew that already um well
let's say he play he moves the rook and you
do something like this and he pushes the pawn
you can just come back and it's the same thing
introducing the grip six belt the
only belt on the market with the no
gut pinch guarantee the grip six is so light and
thin that you'll barely even notice it's there
it's smooth low profile design makes this belt
the most comfortable belt in the world overly
confident much you're damn right because on top
of being the most comfortable belt in the universe
each grip 6 belt comes with our a3 gear and damn
tee meaning if you don't like any belt for any
reason at any time or in any condition you can
just contact us and we'll give you a full refund
thank you so much to gravesix for their
sponsorship and make sure to use pogchamps
20 as a code to get 20 percent off on
any product on their site if you go to
go.chess.com unfortunately the wallets have been
sold at the chest in words but they still have
the chest steam belts and their premium
chest set is available for pre-order
take advantage of that yeah they sent us
a little belt and it had a queen shape
in the buckle i think alex can rock these yes
we did i'm so jealous oh it must be a europe
thing maybe like the mail didn't make it i bet
it's coming though i hope so i'm thinking it's
just taking longer because levy got his socks and
then he almost did a sock reveal and i think yeah
i would love to have one of those as
well and uh again make sure to use
the code until you can during the event it's
a 20 off on their site we are ready to start
the first match of the championship bracket
again these are two of the biggest grinders of
the pak cham series xqc the only participant who
has played in every single edition and sardoche
he has started his chess grind at the beginning
of 2021 playing chess almost every single day
on his stream for hours and hours grinding
through lessons and over 2 800 chess games
so i'm curious how this game will turn out we were
watching earlier andrea the preparation of sqc
with none other than grandmaster hikaru nakamura
what did you think of that london preparation
which will be for the second game not this one
yeah they were preparing against the london which
is my favorite but the games have started so i
think we can hop right in um xcc is not playing
the london i'm a little bit disappointed but we'll
take it and i i will definitely see it by sardo
stardust does love your london system just as much
as as you do i believe e4 and let's see if sardosh
realizes that he is in the game i'm looking at his
screen and for now it doesn't seem like he noticed
that yeah started he was having connection issues
he started with one bar but i don't know what's
going on now please let's try this again this
game started let's try this again take number
two xqc versus sardoche the winner of group b
with the white pieces versus the second place
player of group a sarah i'm going to call my
brother because we have like the same name so
now we're technically related okay i agree that
that's a good call there let's say it called in
the sicilian defense let's see if xqc has made any
preparations against a sicilian or will he just
freestyle it his intuition is extremely good he
played some very sharp games in the group stage
even the gambits that daniel negrano has
played against xqc felix managed to come back
with the most most accurate responses the most
precise responses in the opening which is not
easy to do when you face gambit you please bishop
to c4 and i don't know if he has anything prepped
but his development looks pretty solid so far but
he has been grinding so much and it's definitely
been paying off in his games exactly he played
this setup also against daniana grano he likes
to place the bishop on c4 i guess that comes from
the usual e4e5 openings where we teach everyone
that oh that's a good spot to attack the f7 pawn
and he does the same against the sicilian yeah
i like to call this a reverse london
everything comes back to the london but
all right it's always about the london i like
the setup that stardust has gone for because the
bishop on c4 can be dangerous pointing at that
f7 spot after e6 you make your spawn structure
more solid and the king's safer yeah sardochi
is not gonna be falling through any traps today
i don't think he will you're right
he is the highest rated player
very impressive 1400 rating points he was almost
at 1500 at some stage a week a week or so ago
so it's incredible to see how he started out about
at the rating of 900 in january and he has gained
over 600 rating points since yeah his rating is
very impressive but i think xpc is a very close in
level so even though he's a little bit underrated
i think this matchup is going to be very close
absolutely i don't think anyone is a favorite i i
feel like they are very very even when it comes to
their their expertise in terms of how many games
they have been grinding through over 2000 games of
both of them and how well they did in the group
stage both of them well xqc won his group stage
and sardosh was close to tying the score against
benji fish in that crucial match all right so here
he did do you think that sardochi is playing a
little bit defensive only pushing his pawns one
move not really controlling the center yet what
do you think of sardosh's reply to xqc's opening
i think it's solid and i feel like sardosh has
prepared for this he must have seen that xqc
does have couple of games with this bishop c4
setup so i don't think it came as a surprise
to him also he has been playing very fast
that still has more than 10 minutes oh my god
it's 10 minutes with a five second increment per
move so so far stardust has been collecting time
not spending time yeah i didn't even realize where
all the time went xqc is already down to almost
eight minutes okay i like it he's putting in an
attack the bishop's probably gonna have to retreat
the b3 here he's getting a little bit of
aggressive play b5 is a typical push indeed
in the sicilian later black and developed
the bishop to the long diagonal bishop to b7
i wonder if xqc will choose bishop to b3 or drop
the bishop back to f1 d3 there are also available
squares on that diagonal so let's see which one
is his reference yeah i think both lines are good
i'm taking a quick look at his screen and he is
drawing an arrow to the b3 square so so far good
i like it that would be a very logical
decision to keep the bishop on that diagonal
if he is not worried that the bishop can get
trapped because the only downside of it would
be if black manages to push the a pawn all
the way to a4 then there's no space for the
bishop it's not happening as of now of course
yeah i think this one is the most natural and
easiest to play where if he was retreating here
he might be blocking some of his own pieces so
comfortable play so far for xqc let's listen
in what he thinks about this position i wonder
i promise this knight is not very protected only
by queen which believes you're kind of vulnerable
oh wait a minute queen pawn push double attack
thank you that's another one three at ricardo prep
he gonna go for it now this is no longer
protected though do i care i mean if he did
go queen f3 just bishop b7 right counteracting
right away yes that would be a good response but
sardosh has to find it so let's see first of all
it's a double attack i'm going to go for it okay
i like it putting him under pressure okay let's
bring our board back and show what the idea of
felix is here with queen f3 he is ready to push
his e pawn to e5 and that would mean that both the
knight on f6 and the rook on a8 would be hanging
but unfortunately for him sardosh immediately
plays the best response bishop to b7 another pawn
is pinned you cannot push e5 because that would be
as we know we all know it yeah the thing
with these moves is like box blocks call
them they're serotonin moves it looks nice
because he has this one move threat but now
he pretty much just helped black develop and
now his queen's a little bit pinned yeah i think
if he realizes that the queen though is doing
well in the third rank he can even shift it to
for instance g3 to then try to attack the king on
g8 with the bishop move to h6 that would be a way
to set up a checkmate pattern but no he doesn't
go toward the king he drops the queen back to
e2 so he's i think insisting on this idea
that the pawn at some point should be pushed
yeah he really wants to attack in the center
which i think is a pretty pretty solid plan so
far i wonder if sardoche will follow up with the
knight development that would be the next for him
to finish the development of the queen side plays
the knight on c6 or d7 both of them are logical
yeah so far i'm a big fan of both of their
openings definitely this is very high level
opening preparation i would say but from excuse
his side i'm not even sure it's preparation i
think he has just a really good intuition
for chess already after 2000 games played
i agree now this is an interesting move he's
a little bit over extending his pawns but
now if the knight comes to the side he
doesn't necessarily have squares to go so
where do you think xcc should be rerouting his
knights good question i i feel like knight a4
would be um the square he's looking at at the
same time i wonder if he will notice that now the
e4 pawn is no longer well enough guarded that was
the knight the knight on c3 was protecting the e4
pawn and now the bishop and the black knight from
f6 are attacking the pawn they could be taking on
could be the first fallen pawn and he was he
was trying so hard to push this guy too but
might not even get the chance yeah that's the bit
of a downside of this queen move that he played
because earlier the rook two was guarding the
pawn the queen the knight so many pieces of felix
were protecting the central palm but you don't
want the capture to be starting with the queen
he has the strongest defenders but he just can't
take because of this little bishop it's very
sad both his rook and his queen working together
hard but all right there goes his pawn it's okay
can come back from it i feel like because he's
ahead in development he does have compensation
if he keeps playing very aggressive and developing
moves developing meaning that he also still needs
to develop the c1 bishop and bring in the other
rook as well bring the other rook to d1 possibly
so if he would for instance now um make a
developing move with the bishop or chase the
knight away with f3 if he has to oh he goes okay
f3 i kind of like it i mean a little bit blocking
this bishop but it is creating some weaknesses
on this diagonal here but if he's not falling for
any checks i don't think there'll be any traps
i fully agree with you and now it is over to
sardosh to see where do you place the knight and
there could be tactics on the e6 square i feel
like if the knight simply goes back to f6 we we
could see a sacrifice on e6 that would be a very
nice sack actually uh some of the chatters were
pointing out the sacrifice earlier in the game but
this is this is hard because even if he goes to
c5 we could take and sack so he has to play very
precisely here to g5 i'm not even sure what
is it that sardosh is supposed to be playing
here because as you said doesn't matter if
you go to f6 or c5 in both cases the knight
the knight will be taken on c5 and then the
e6 sacrifice is possible let's just show
for a moment until sardos is thinking this
knight f6 position and what happens oh okay
he hasn't alexandra your idea here i think i think
that knight on c5 will be taken i think phillips
this would be a killer tactic if he found
technically he just played a gambit here
from knight takes e4 like if he's playing
perfectly that was a pretty nice pawn sacrifice
indeed let's show it on on our analysis board i
feel like because it's a it's a long variation
to take on c5 which eliminates the defender
of the e6 pawn after dtx c5 knight takes e6
sacrificing the knight and if the pawn takes
it queen takes e6 is a check which also attacks
the bishop on e7 and you cannot defend with rook
to f7 thanks to this very powerful bishop on b3
i wonder if felix will see it i wonder if he
spots this tactical [ __ ] and take the knight
and then sacrifice on e6 that would be five head
absolute five head if he sees it yeah i'll show
the line again but sorry don't look so stressed
man what do you think he spotted it do you think
he that there was danger he did look look at him
he looks he looks like he's sweating i think he
knows but i don't know if xqc knows maybe we can
see if he's going to find this line he played
a3 instead which is not a bad move and it could
still allow that sacrifice later i didn't give him
a free nice pawn development
this is fine i missed this shot
what oh the issue is that
now sardoche had a chance to
trade the knight for the bishop that bishop
was a key piece for this tactical motive
how do you prefer this yes sardosh definitely
saw the tactic did not want to give him a sec
man that would have been because then my palms
aren't towered and i can still push them up
and then i can i get this plate
whenever this queen is out of position
what is that not even that bad
if you leave spawn there i'm gonna have
triple stacked pawns that's terrible
let's see normal puns that is true how much
we're good we're down by one
pump but we're actually good here
i do i need to do better moves my time
i need to just make moves make moves
i'm overthinking it just chill out man you hurry
he he's still on the same sacrifice doesn't he
i think it wouldn't work the same way if we bring
back our analysis board because now without the
bishop if he ends up taking on e6 the rook will
be defending at the end of the line you tell us
the rook f7 d5 is a great move by sardosh i was
going to say he reacted with the central palm push
allowing the trade on b4 but now after bishop
takes b4 this bishop is really well placed
attacking the rook on e1 and then he could develop
his knight so his upper pawn has a really healthy
pawn structure and he just needs to finish
the clean side development yeah unfortunately
his triple stack did not survive very long
we're down to a double stack or double pawns
but i kind of like the stack terminology
better no triple stack we do have the
double stack and the pawn then for felix so
he needs to compensate for it with aggressive
attacking ideas let's see what he can come up
with and will sardos trade the bishop on d2 or
will he drop it back because if he preserves the
bishop if he keeps it and goes back to that say d6
he would also have the pair of bishops which is
a strategic advantage on an advanced level and
i feel like this is already advanced level so he
might actually consider keeping it on the board
yeah another thing to note he's also up on the
clock so it is looking pretty good for sardoshier
okay you chose to offer the trade which is also
good you want to trade when you're up material
but i'm not sure that he should allow them before
so i agree with you that trading overall it could
be beneficial to him but knife bishop takes eight
takes b4 that bottom b4 will be vulnerable and
queen to b5 would attack both the bishop on b7 and
the pawn on b4 so xqc has a chance to win the pawn
back if he spots that although queen b5 queen e7
that's still not over but it would make sardosh's
life more difficult to develop the knight from
b8 at least it is exactly what you're saying he's
a little bit down so he needs to get an attack
going and this could be the opportunity for that
let's see if he spots it if we go
over to his stream and listen in
oh he's looking at it maybe
there we go he's gonna do it
well i don't know what i'm doing
here no he found like the good idea
what know what i'm doing he gave up
on it and are you excited about that
check yeah he should have trusted that
idea but sometimes it has instincts
nope it's a bit too late for the sacrifice though
yeah no longer working god a little bit too late
move take take is that good it's decent it's very
it's very unpredictable he's really over thinking
the issue is here when you don't know
what to do you spend so much time
looking at all pretty decent moves but he's
already down more than half the time so rook trade
it's not bad he ends up playing knight to c5 if we
bring our board back i think um the reason why the
other move order would have been better and he was
drawing an arrow to the b5 square so he literally
almost played queen to b5 now the difference is
if if for instance they trade on a1 rook takes
even rook takes a1 and then queen to b6 could be
somewhat annoying because you have both of your
knights on that diagonal hanging and you need to
find a way in which you can guard the c5 knight
so that it will not fall there's a pin over the d4
night and both knights are vulnerable i'm not even
sure what's the best way to continue there sardosh
is taking the rook he is trading on a1 let's see
if he follows up with queen to b6 or any similar
idea about the knights being somewhat exposed
and vulnerable on the diagonal the long the long
diagonal yeah this is getting into a really tough
position here he didn't even have counter play
to take the bishop and try to attack the queen
because then he would have given him a check
earlier so he is in a little bit of a messy
position oh wow and he plays it sardoch has been
playing so accurate he's playing really well and
after queen to b6 i wonder if if the only move
for xqc is either a sad rook c1 when black can
continue with rook c8 bringing yet another piece
to the attack or he will eventually need to trade
queens he has to probably place the queen on b5
the move he was looking at earlier and offer a
queen trade before it's too late now the house is
on fire so he i think he should trade queens yeah
queen week five here i mean once again trading
down material but his knights are pretty strong
he has pressure on the bishop he has the open file
so a queen trade he still has chances for sure
i agree let's go over to a history actually
wait a second he has made a decision
but it's not it's not the end of the painful
part and how difficult it will be with that pin
if sardoche continues with rook to c8
and i think he has to play that's
the last way you can defend
or just move back like this then
and i can fork this oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah move queen here and fork that
those knight frogs are good ideas but
unfortunately it's not happening they don't
work regarding the square and now rook
c8 that is the best move that sardoche
has found is that what i can do here wow
he's going to trade he's into it is he oh
we could bring our board back and show what's
happening in this position with that c5 knight
unfortunately for xqc this is now pinned through
the c5 through the diagonal knight to a6 adds yet
another attacking piece to what's going on on this
c5 square that's the key square here that's the
key piece the c5 knight is going to fall there's
not another piece that white can bring here to
the defense the d4 knight unfortunately is unable
to guard their body on c5 you cannot protect it
yeah queen b5 was the only way he has the same
situation when he pinned this queen earlier
and now we can't save the piece it's getting
really tough he doesn't even have any like
tactics try to stack oh okay is playing knight to
d7 to try to bait sardo but he's losing his rook
yeah that's so quick he didn't even have to
double check he was so confident that he's taking
the queen and then the rook so both queens
are off of the board but this is now an extra
rook for sardosh yeah i mean look at he looks
like he's at a serious chest right now he's so
focused you know when like half your face is
covered by your hands you're in your zone he's
been killing it he's certainly in the zone and
he's on his way of claiming the first game with
an extra rook he's about to take on b2 as well
i think he'll just collect that pawn and then
possibly in the future push in the center or try
to win the b3 pawn as well to create a past pawn
i can't tell if silence there's no is yeah is it
not even any music oh there he is we now do hear
his stream but i think i think it's gonna be the
background music and the silence of his thoughts
yeah i don't think he's saying anything much
here but luckily i excuse that hikaru for next
round so anything can happen true true true
let's see if xqc the gm he carries preparation
against the london can fight back in the next game
unfortunately for xqc this end game is just
very unlikely that one can go wrong it would
take a mouse slip or time pressure that could
get to black but stardosh has more time as well
so yeah more time i mean this this extra rook
is just yeah all the fawns are gonna fall his
knights can't defend everything i don't know
where he's trying to run maybe he's trying to
set up a stalemate or something i think so i
think he places the king on h4 because you're
right that could still be a pattern if the king
has nowhere to go and he manages to sacrifice yeah
actually if there was no pawn no night and
no other night we would have had a stalemate
it was a great plan we just had to remove some
more pieces he's trying to stack them he's going
to give them all he's going to give everything i
think that's what we're going to see exactly and
we shall see we shall see it will if it will work
out xqc has had his fair share of stalemates in
previous sport chimps editions and i think he's
very well aware that that's his last chance here
that is true but something tells me from sardosh's
place so far he's not going to fall for any rookie
mistakes and he's going for the b3 pawn which is
very logical once you eliminate that pawn you have
a pass pawn three squares away from promotion
so rick takes b3 and then move the rook away
so that you can freely push the pawn toward
b1 yeah this is killer xqc decided against his
stillmate player now he's defending his knights
oh he doesn't take the b3 comes to attack f4
interesting i would have i would have predicted
that the capture will happen maybe sardoch is
considering that it could be a checkmate
pattern he wanted to take on f4 he can still
do it after h6 check and king h4 rook takes
f4 yeah he should have tried to retreat to g3
let's see where the route goes there aren't too
many squares phonically enough for that rook
just hear yesterday maybe f1 you should
just come chase the spawn and then
the finishing touch will be this passer here
g5 is a great move too to support the rook with
that palm push so black is up a rook and also
a couple of past pawns at this stage he didn't
take the b-bomb but he also has the d-pawn as a
passport so d4 and then trying to push d3 would be
another way oh he's going for the stalemate plan
and he's gonna give everything yeah stalemate plan
and also knight forks and felix wants to take on
e6 to win the rook and if king takes a fight here
he has another knight fork knight to g6
unfortunately for him he's giving away all his
knights for the rook but he's really trying he's
really trying yeah the sad part like even with
this nice tactic i mean he just has this little
king against and his two pawns not much going here
now the rook is gone for the two nights and
what remains on the board is still unfortunately
very very tough for xqc it's two extra pieces and
four pawns four best ones for ourselves all right
okay they did trade how to catch up here well
okay and the the stalemate chances are looking
better and better what can i say we gotta
push that honey here we go now it's just
the king against the world but i i don't think i
don't know if his dreams are going to come true
let's see if it's going to be stalemate or
checkmate we are just a few moves away from
seeing the reality if quinterjeet he shouldn't
bring the queen that close he brings the king
in and now it's checkmate on the board for his
game no mercy at all wow yeah excuse he really
threw everything he had for that stalemate but
sardoche played very clean that was a killer game
that was indeed a killer game and we're gonna
be back with a second game with colors reversed
as you mentioned for the next game it's gonna be
the preparation of gm hikaru against the london
system so hopefully that will go better for xqc
because he did have his chances in this game too
with that sacrifice on e6 if he has spotted it
yeah if if they if sardos plays into hikaru's prep
i think maybe we could go into an armageddon
let's take a look at xqc stream and we're
going to be back in a few minutes with the
second game program 3 presented by grip6
attack [ __ ] okay oh attack
packages do
okay
you guys well my name's not starting
well when's the start next match
four pillars of regeneration to heal all nations
we work with and not against because we are a
part of this we've never been apart from
this saw hands feel through the soils past
our feet touch on the blades of grass raid all
these voices into a beautiful tapestry find those
similarities we all share in these breaths that we
breathe this home of ours sustains us but needs us
so together we'll move through this long
night and inspire us all to come to life
thank you so much again to guyaki for helping
pakistan be possible helping us to make this
event be possible and they are sharing cases
of the year by mate to celebrate 25 years of
regenerative year by mate all you need to
do you already know it you already should
know it by now spam those goyaki emotes in the
chat with a chance to win a case also to share
their celebration guayaki emotes right now
right now let me say when i they sent us a big
big package of a bunch and when i drank those
i gained 100 points in bullet true story
i need my kids to actually i have received my
kids but i need more kids i need more i think
any caffeine kind of pays off in bullets
but uh this is like a healthier version so
absolutely absolutely right and we have a lift
off i believe for the second game sardoche won
the first game meaning that xqc is in a must-win
situation he has to win if he doesn't win
eliminated the london system android's already
getting excited let's see the gm he preparation
this is the game i've been looking forward to
man because i don't play a single other opening
as white except the london system so when i see
it i get really excited because it's you know the
one thing i've studied a lot all right so far so
good knight to c6 is the move that he was showing
to xqc with the setup being e6 and bishop to d6
so let's see if felix follows up along the lines
of the super gm preparation yeah i remember
when we popped into a stream it seemed like
they would get into position where they trade
this bishop i'm curious if that'll happen i
don't trade it very often so we talked about okay
i'm losing memory this is according to the plan e6
and sargon
oh no
no he forgot the plan king
check pawn move pawn move back
then who knows
trend the juicer i think he
just wanted to scare his him
it's just a little bit of
scared he doesn't yeah yeah
okay yeah he was looking at bishop check which
okay sneak it back f4 for a moment because we have
the jungle system expert with us andrea what do
you think of this f4 push if you could show it
on our board well um actually f4 is uh incorrect
and so now i don't think we're gonna be playing
into the ikaru position but i mean it's it's okay
but now we've kind of created this weakness and
normally you want your bishop to be defending here
a little bit a premature pawn push that is from
the london expert i see i see so you wouldn't have
pushed f4 but even if it's not perhaps the best
approach by white sardoch does have his plan to
avoid the bishop trade and support the e5 square
and he immediately jumps to e5 with his knight
and then the next night the other night could
come to f3 as well so i like that he's got a setup
very very clear in his mind and he's going for it
yeah this is still a pretty common plan for
the london he just pushed surely but it's still
pretty easy to play pretty comfortable but he
might have some king side weaknesses depending
if xqc packs in the center as well but he did not
have that prep so it will be harder to find that's
the issue this f4 push whether it was the best or
not it has prevented the gm recovery preparation
where they mainly were focusing on positions with
the trade of bishops now the trade of the bishop
for the e5 knight how do you see the opening of
the f-file in this system i i think i mean this
is okay i i think these pawns are pretty strong
and that now we have the bishop pair sometimes i
get really annoyed when you know they copy you
and then they come do the same thing and get
their own pawns and then even push f5 too but i
don't know if xqc is going to come for the center
let's see if he's going toward e4 with the knight
or d7 the knight doesn't have any other options
where it wouldn't be taken for free but yeah i
must say what sardochi is doing sometimes when i
get paired against really high rated players
i i make sure that i'm not playing theory
because i feel like then you kind of have better
chances even if it's slightly wrong all right we
got a knight d7 playing safe that's solid and
the night later could jump to f8 if the king
needs more protection i wonder if sardoche will
continue with bishop d3 and castle king's side
or will he even consider castle queenside yeah
i think bishop d3 is the right plan he probably
pushed c3 to avoid some knight before attacking
the bishop his development is looking good
c3 is the traditional push i guess he may have
been worried about bishop to d3 knight b4 yeah
so the hard thing here and i was going to ask you
what do you think the best plan for xqc to develop
is because his pieces are all pretty passive and
all bunched up together and retreated already
it's tough you're right with the the knight
on d7 the way of the bishop oh f6 though
i was gonna say i think you need to try to
to explode that central structure of white
f6 is the way to go but bishop h4 by stardust
immediately to pin the pawn he is so fast no
this is yeah this is a great because his pieces
could not develop anywhere he has to break through
somewhere but sardosa is playing these fantastic
moves so fast this is a really tough situation
for sqc because he did have the right plan but
now you are not able to take on e5 because of
the pin and pushing the pawn to g5 would be too
committal he should definitely not weaken his king
oh no no no he thinks it thanks banana
saw your faults okay i mean maybe it can
still turn out well but i feel like this
is too committal yeah now just excuses
king is almost naked and afraid look at all
these holes but you can bring in the troops maybe
and he could be winning the pawn so i guess his
reasoning is that if the bishop goes back to g3
then he could take multiple times on e5 queen
to g4 by sardosh to now pin the g pawn as well
he's definitely a master of pins spinning now
yeah also the second pawn on g5 i wonder is it
tricky sacrifice is now on e5 because if knight
takes e5 pawn takes and then you take again on e5
with the knight you have given up a piece but the
queen has to leave and then you could trap a trap
not but take the bishop on h4 except if the queen
goes to g3 right because then we can maintain in
that case i think my plan is ruined yes it was
a good idea wait wait wait no damn the bishop
because then you can move the king away from the
jeep and the bishop has nowhere to go i didn't
see that coming but it makes some sense that's
true i think i mean yeah white is still going to
be killing this position yeah and it looks too
dubious looks too suspicious because the bishop
could have taken on g5 so we are in the midst
of our analysis why excuses simply pushes h6 to
structure which maybe it was probably safer
than sacrificing but this is still it's
just so much attack on his king so early and
he's so behind development on the queen side
i think h6 is indeed a really good
practical decision in order to make the king
safer and he could in the future push the f
pawn now that the g pawn is so well guarded
he could go f5 to try to chase that queen away f5
would be a really nice way to try to block this
opening here on his king and then maybe he could
even bring in his queen to defend eventually
and then again those ideas would be possible
that after f5 queen g3 you move the king away
from the g file and the bishop on h4
is trapped at some point it should work
yeah so now it's up to sardosh maybe he's gonna
see this idea try to prevent it and play something
safe like we're treating as bishop or even more
aggressive i wonder i guess he doesn't have any
sack idea like queen h5 take the bishop give
some checks and clean up his pawns there's a
lot of ideas for white wait a second he won the
first game so if he finds a way in which he can
force a perpetual you would be claiming the match
so it's it makes a lot of sense for him to look
for queen h5 queen g6 and try to give perpetual
yeah actually i think this is a perpetual because
king f8 queen check and here then we have a
mate threat so so there actually is a force
well if they take the bishop though
so queen h5 is an interesting name
i think you have just solved the match if he spots
queen to h5 which either is with a really strong
attack for white or if the bishop is accepted
it's a perpetual check for white that's all that
sardoche needs and this is the match situation i
think if it was just a normal game why should try
to play this for a win because the position is
better but with a draw and only a draw you can
you can wow the next stage to the semi-finals
he plays bishop instead which is which is very
ambitious but it may not be oh my god
it's now the advantages in black side i
i think maybe the plan is f5 but the eval bar
took a big drop i think he has stepped into the
sacrifice i was trying to make it knight takes e5
you've been oh oh the knight one not even the f5
okay let's play it out live so that when d takes
another knight takes and now the queen and the
bishop are hanging and if you drop the queen
back to e2 to guard the d3 bishop then the h4
bishop is taken so you cannot guard both bishops
wow wow okay i don't want to miss it let's see
if he's gonna if xqc is gonna find it
yeah f5 was a little bit of a safer move
still blocking the attack but that was a really
complicated tactic there f5 push my xqc which
is again logical but i'm afraid he's pushing
star dodge to finding queen to h5 afterwards
but if it's a draw he's eliminated so again
because it's the knockout stage already xqc
has to win to earn a tiebreaker yeah excuse
me had two very killer tactics in each game
but there are both you know a couple moves
of calculating they're pretty hard to spot
these are no puzzle rush tactics that you get in
your first 10 puzzles or something now this was
very complex the sacrifice on e5 the first time
i went for the sacrifice it didn't even work so
yeah i didn't even see it the second time
around so if queen h5 i think sardosh will
be claiming the match because i don't even see
a way for black to avoid the checks or not lose
the h6 pawn so it's either way too dangerous the
attack or you accept the fact that you can take
the bishop but then you will not run away from
the checks any other queen move i do think that
xqc has a chance because if you drop the queen
back to g3 again black could consider moving away
the king from the g file and then the h4 bishop is
trapped again this is the tactical motif we were
trying to make work and i think it's working yeah
this would be pretty nice because the queen will
also defend g5 so it's not even like white can
sack a lot you know what do we miss wait into g3
g3 wow stardust didn't play queen to h5
but places the queen on g3 so let's see
if xqc will not by moving the king away i i
might am i moving to the atria i don't know
i feel a bit more concerned about the f5 but it's
just my intuition i'm not i'm not 100 sure but if
he moves the king away from the g5 let's say king
to h7 then the bishop on h4 will so this is still
very tricky though i like that he didn't choose
to take the pawn which would have helped excuse
his pawn structure but now we have this isolated
pawn and this open file let's go back to exclusive
stream and see if he's thinking of rook to g8
or queen g5 i'm gonna go for it i'm going for it
oh no i lost i'm so dumb
he's giving up no reason
it's not bad though it's fine
check i realize that that's only a check yeah
i think it's really easy to get that losing
mentality when i don't even know i force trade
because i'm plus two and i wanna go for trades
in a better position even with better
pawns too thinking to go for trades
yeah he's thinking about some some
crazy fort move here he's gonna find it
no he won't before i don't think there's
any pork knight g6 doesn't lead to anything
if i were to stack my juices
like this he would just go boom
what does that even do from
take queen good castle
got some kick play well now we're in the
end game the next he has the advantage
and he goes for rook j it's very logical to
try to take the pawns on the g yes i just
okay
the queen side development indeed we need
to get that c8 bishop l so b6 is a good uh
unfortunately is his center pawn that across is
fine on whites are really holding his bishop back
i like knight to b6 because that also frees the d7
square for the bishop so he could do that exactly
exactly that's the way to go connecting the
rooks you can bring them on time easy development
i need to figure what figure
out a way to attack that
that's decent
the pawn push this piece is rolling
right now i need to get it out thank you
let's bring our board back for a moment and see
some of these options uh again this is a great
chance for xqc to make a comeback sardoch is
leading 1-0 in this match and it's already the
knockout stage meaning that xqc has to win this
game he's now up a piece and all that sardosh has
is a pawn to compensate for it not much especially
considering that it's not a past pawn and they're
stacked as we say not doubled exactly stacked
pawns oh and now g4 offering the pawn i don't know
if sardosh miscalculated it that there are two
pieces of black attacking that square yes he takes
the pawn wow oh he was planning to win it back
but i mean black can just defend his pawn here
he might have miscalculated that now there's h5
porsche wow the pawn and the rook on g3 is stuck
so it's not only that he lost the player anywhere
the phone on its own wouldn't be that much of a
disaster but the fact that you cannot move your
rook ever how will he activate the g3 rook oh
no i was gonna say just has to watch out for this
night check he's been preparing but we all right
oh okay so xqc did step into the night fork but
it's not the end of the world if if he will take
one of the minor pieces for it so he can either
take on g6 or move the king and then take back
on f8 yeah there's there's a few i think even
after i think he has already made his decision
before we could have listened and he does take on
g6 but now he has to be careful with those paws
the h5 pawn is hanging and if he loses that pawn
the g4 pawn two will fall yeah he only has one
way to defend his pawn bishop eight he right now
even though he just lost exchange he's still doing
much better because he has this past pawn here but
he can't drop these pawns yes he's got two minor
pieces for the rook but he has to guard the pawns
and you're right andrew it's not so easy to find
bishop e8 or or something tricky with the
knight jumps if if he gets over to to f5
but that's way too dank knight t7 to then go
knight oh he's dropping them these were the key
the key to the success oh no oh and now it's back
in white's favor the g3 rook was completely dead
and now it's back in the game after the g4 pawn
he's breaking free from the chains of this pawn
and taking two pawns almost and there goes
another one oh man oh no and the issue with
the king to h6 is that after rook age war wow or
bishop g4 there will be checkmate patterns too now
yeah we got the rook roller here holding back
the king we just have to take this pawn wow
what a turn of events excuse me with the piece
of but he did not see that night for coming
rook fade would have been a logical move
if it wasn't for the tactical pattern
and now this should be mating too uh rook takes
g4 king goes back to h6 and this cover check mate
and if king to f5 and now it's just
made in one oh god oh my goodness yes
yes
his quarterfinals 2-0 against sqc moves on to
the semi-finals we will be back with the players
in a few minutes to discuss everything that has
happened what a roller coaster and what a missed
chance by sqc in the second game that was a very
close game poor guy but sardosh sure he he grinded
these two games he stayed in it when he was losing
and he got that one tactic saved the game that
night fork did turn the tables and did secure the
win for star dodge we're gonna take a short break
and then we will be back with the players
to discuss all this action from the quarter
finals of the championship bracket blockchain
3 presented by grif6 will be back shortly
xd yeah rook over was
you got to win this man look we
got some sweaters in this top this
[ __ ] ain't gonna be free i wish i was
rolling though he was actually rolling
why is this good
what was that even cheaper oh bang
than bing then i have a i have a fork
coot saw that i'm just saying you
right now coot saw that cooter saw that
i'm sad i feel like you should have won that
game five thousand of you are now manually
breathing dude i had it damn that dude i had it
i'm telling you [ __ ] up because i think he made
at least a hundred thousand people just manually
breathe you see i finally got a girlfriend
so i don't have much time come on bro thanks
for everything oh we're also on chess.com
so [ __ ] 200 000 people are now manually
breathing bang i guess that's the most value
anyone's ever gotten out of a teacher yes wonders
well i mean my king was the best initiative
dude he played so sick too he played so
sick because even without any blunders
sardoche basically went all in
with an attack and he fended it off
he fended off the entire attack and then
just unfortunately it works how does it work
i think sardosh is beatable is this crazy
i think sardosha is definitely beatable
because sardoche after getting i think up on
time after his first eight moves or something
like he was literally up on time because he
moved faster than five seconds every move
ended up taking four minutes for four moves
and like he like he cares so much about winning
that i think it makes him worse at the game
maybe that's crazy to say but he cares so
much about winning he's so sweaty about it
that when it really comes down to the wire
like he can't handle the pressure like if
you got a minute to play and all you want
in this world is to win that's too much man
that sucks though i wanted it to at least go to
overtime i just want to see the new overtime as
well who plays next mizzy yeah mizzy's doing this
quiz i gave him i gave a bunch of streamers the
internet's hardest questions logically world's
gay is dead right okay lasagna oh it's this is
the question okay here's a here's a question
for everybody at home if you have two lasagnas
that you've baked and then you stacked one on
top of the other how many lasagnas do you have
still tastes like water which means that didn't
help us at all water's a terrible example for this
oh [ __ ] thank you for the sub god why is this
making me hungry yeah i'm going to order all of
you guys by the way just put whatever you want i'm
getting it from burger king whatever you guys want
uh my mom's on the way she's on like route 33. you
have to disclose when it's sponsored burger king
if you guys segment just put it whatever you want
in chat she'll get it my mom reads chat and drives
um no she doesn't wait lud just came in here
no one eats burger king if they're not
paid is that one of the questions led
will you eat burger king unpaid i'm gonna be
real with you lud my grandma used to get me
two double cheeseburgers and a milkshake
every time and you know why i love burger king
was made last week and one today
you know why i like burger king
burger king was good because of not the food
but the atmosphere man it was the car that you
got to sit in eating your big mac with the
crown on your head and it was just divine
what the [ __ ] playhouse was a better vibe than
that [ __ ] nowadays the playhouse i look at it
and i'm like damn that's a disgusting pit of like
toxic waste but back in the day the play pit that
[ __ ] was i'm too smart for my own good if you
bake two lasagnas and then he also said big mac
i love going to bk and get my big mac and you
stack one lasagna on top of each other okay
here's my argument for why it's two if you bake a
lasagna and then let's say the next week you bake
another lasagna and you stack one on top of the
other how many would you have you would say two
boom
you argue the stacking is all that matters
your answer would have to be yes which makes no
sense you're [ __ ] here's the thing that is
destroyed that becomes the issue i totally agree
yes but the problem is it is the
crust does it start a new lasagna
it does start a new lasagna that's
where the issue comes into play
welcome back to the coverage of pogchamps 3
presented by grips we're grape six we are being
joined by d heroes of the first ever championship
bracket clash between sardoche and xqc sir dosh
congratulations this has been a nail-biting finish
and xqc you almost made a miracle happen as i was
telling you while we were getting ready for the
interview let's begin with you sardosh about first
of all your thoughts on these two games and how do
you feel about making making it to the semi-finals
well it was very very stressful because uh i
knew xqc was really good in open position and
so otherwise so i could get punished if i go for
tactics so well i i tried to close it up a bit uh
i knew he had the preparation for my london system
by icaru just before the stream but sadly i had my
coach telling me exactly how to actually quintus
so i'm really sorry but my coach phone on this one
is that a shout out to blitzstream kevin
boardy or nemo hey kevin kevin on this one yeah
but on this c4 i must admit i would
have never found it myself by myself
that was kevin kevin body yeah sorry sorry i'm
really sorry but the game was really intense
i put myself in a so hard situation in the white
game and you you did so well with your pawns i was
in so much trouble and well i i gave up my my
bishop and went like okay maybe my maybe my
knight will do the job and he did at the end
so i'm proud that well that was a bit lucky
yeah the bishop was stuck on
the left side of the map and
i'm just kidding yeah yeah i thought uh the
bishop and the queen were uh were like stack uh
upper left uh but the only thing is that uh at mid
there's like a a four trade i could have done that
i didn't see and the computer kept saying it wrong
wrong like he didn't want me to do it but i i
didn't see it again get aggressive with
it are you talking about the night fork or
in the very first game yeah the night sacrifice
should knight take nails yeah that would have
been nice right before f5 anna pointed this one
out yeah in first game i had either there was a
tactic i missed it yeah in both games actually it
was a very instructive motive but such a difficult
one to find um andrea i thank you for sharing the
right moment there with knight takes e5 that's the
one felix was referring to that here you could
have sacrificed the knight and now uh the queen
is hanging the bishop on d3s hanging and also
the h4 bishop will be in the area if the queen
moves away from the g5 so you would have won
the pete's back and you're up couple of pawns
oh yeah of course of course yeah easy right
easy chance this was very this was a very very
difficult very advanced level tactical pattern
but even the way you played felix you found a way
to make sure that the queen has to go to g3 so you
pushed f5 with the idea to push the queen down and
then you stepped away from the g5 with the king
it was very logical because the bishop is trapped
yeah yeah um yo my pieces couldn't breathe
man i was stuck there that that position
was true my king felt so alone look at him look
at him he's like yeah i was pretty sure even if
i trade my my bishop i could still be winning this
activity but well i'm not sure exactly but well i
yeah it's it's really hard to to play
this game when your your pieces are behind
and you can't move them yeah but that
was that was my idea when i put my
my knight on on e5 if you would actually take
it i would take me with my opponent kick your
bishop out with your night out in a way you
you couldn't you couldn't play anymore you
your back pieces so yes that was the idea
behind the pitbull plan actually yeah i mean
uh i've been have you been grinding the game
out because you have a pretty solid mid game
you've been playing a lot of it
you've been playing a lot of uh chess
uh i i didn't i started like two months ago um
and i played like mostly chess for the last two
months honestly i just played like eight hours
a day so i just yeah i'm just obsessed so yeah
i play a lot in this time yeah you improve
really fast whenever you play a lot in one day
like uh like a lot of hours in a row i feel like
you um you know you get there you get a lot of
improvement i noticed yeah yeah when i when i'm
on something i just dedicate my my life into it
so today is chess tomorrow i don't know yeah
but that was some really intense game honestly
the two of you have been on a huge grind for
the whole event as you said xkc uh you started
basically pogchamps we we can thank thank to you
and the collaboration with you and hikaru that the
entire chess boom started and the the series the
park champs series grew out of that collaboration
and now you're here for your third
pogchamps unfortunately they will
need to say goodbye to you but will we
see you be back for puck chance four
yeah yeah it'll be good it'll be good uh when i
come back i'll be uh stronger than ever and i'll
i'll take the crown then it wouldn't be
awesome to get to every match yep okay
that has been the first of our quarter-finals
with sardos winning and qualifying to the
semifinals we don't know his opponent
yet it will depend on the other match as
you see on that side of the bracket we have the
quarterfinals between ludwig and logic coming up
next that will be tomorrow but today we still have
one more clash and that is the winner of group a
benji fishy against group b's second place player
poker professional daniel negrano so we're gonna
have one of the best fortnight players in the
world against poker legend daniel negranu after a
short break we'll be back with that clash function
three presented by grip6 and the reminder on the
format because i almost forgot to mention that in
the championship bracket it's slightly different
we have an eliminator system oh we don't
want to show the format it's it's okay i
was just reading what's on my screen the bracket
stage consists of a single elimination system
time control is the same two games with the time
control of 10 minutes five second increment but in
case of a tie there will be a sudden death blitz
game five minutes no increment until someone
wins and that is indeed how the next match
will go down as well we're gonna take a short
break and then we are back with the quarter
finals between benji fishy and daniel negrano
against benji fishy um so i thought that actually
the two parents he could have gotten it was
it was the best possible pairing um that he
could have had and he played really really well
all right you guys so i'm gonna i'm going to
um go over the games now then i'll talk more
we'll watch and i'll watch the match and
i'll talk about so e4 uh he went and i
don't want to play the second highest rate
of player well that's because benji fishy um
smokes sardo's 2-0 in their individual match
that's why uh because benji just crushed crushed
sardos so i'm not sure that you can actually
say that sardosh is the is this is the highest
rated is he the best player unclear unclear
all right so e4 and now here starters play c5
uh which is the sicilian defense now here xqc goes
bishop c4 now just for sure um what i would say is
i think that xqc should start the other order
play knight to f3 pawn to d6 and now push the
pawn on center now regardless of the second
move d6 knight c6 whatever second move black
plays even e6 they're one two three moves you
always play d4 with your next move and actually
after pawn takes knight takes knight f6 here you
can now go knight to c3 and um sargeras would have
played asics and you can play bishop c4 once
again and get the same opening uh this is the
souzan sicilian it was the favorite of the former
world chess champion bobby fischer so instead xcc
goes bishop c4 d6 knight f3 knight of six knights
e3 pretty good stuff e6 castles bishop e7 and now
he plays d4 so we end up transposing back into the
sews and sicilian with bishop z4 as i pointed out
before this was the favor of the former world
chess champion um bobby fischer he really loved
to play this against the night or so a6 rookie one
b5 now here bishop b3 is a little bit preferable
or maybe pawn to or um but not not a bad move
by any stretch so now here starters castles
xpc goes queen f3 now again not to get too
deep into the weeds of what the theory is here
but a better way to play this would be to play
pawn to f4 with the idea of playing f5 and trying
to rip open this long diagonal for your bishop
and the only way to sort of get at these two
pawns here because you can't sacrifice is to play
f4 and go f5 and just rip open this diagonal force
it open so for example let's just say black goes
bishop b7 you play pawn to f5 and after e5 knight
f3 you'll you'll notice that this diagonal is
open now for the bishop feel a lot of scope here
um so it's very important that you try to rip open
this diagonal because right now the the pawn sort
of on e6 it closes this diagonal since the pawn
behind it protects it so it would have been um
would have been really really really important so
instead he goes queen f3 not a bad move bishop b7
queen to e2 now again very hard to play this on
the fly but probably what you should do is play
pawn to a3 to prevent this pawn push which removes
the knight from the center and then following that
what you do is let's say knight d7 you can now
play queen g3 with multiple ideas let's just say
black plays a random move like knight b6 you go
bishop takes pawn pawn takes bishop knight takes
and not only do you attack the queen and fork the
queen the rook but you also are threatening to go
checkmate with the queen on g7 so black would
have to play something like rook to f7 and now
you just take the queen of your way ahead um so
this would have been something that's good let
me turn on those sounds again one second um so
so a3 would have been good and also let's just
say black was knight c5 you can now potentially
play bishop h6 lining up a pin and threatening
another checkmate with the queen and the bishop
here and if black pushes you just take a rook
so this would have been really really good um
it's a really good idea again very very hard to
find i'd say borderline impossible if you're not
pretty advanced or you haven't studied the opening
so it goes queen e2 b4 knight a4 knight
takes e4 very well played by sardosh
and now f3 is played here by xqc and actually let
me turn on the bar for this as well um so now this
this again very advanced move the computer will
say you play bishop f6 and you're much better um
so this is this is one move that can be good that
can be played here um and black's better you can
play knight c5 or knight f6 both moves are also
possible um but this move is you're not going
to see this at an amateur level it's just too
hard um so here the two moves that you consider
really are knight f6 or knight c5 now starters
plays knight c5 looks like a logical move um but
after knight c5 there's a very strong idea which
is knight takes pawn takes and knight takes e6
and this is actually winning um because after
black recaptures knight you take with the queen
and you hit the king on g8 but also you're gonna
take the bishop on e7 because your rook and queen
are attacking it and if black goes rook to f7
you just take because the bishop holds the queen
and if king h8 you just trade uh trade on e7 and
now you'll see black has five pawns white has
six pawns and it's very easy development you
just bring the bishop and bring the rooks in
stack them and white is close to winning here
so uh this would have been winning for xc again
very hard to find he plays a3 takes he takes for
the pawn d5 is played here by sardosh they trade
all pretty standard here and this was probably
the last critical moment that xec had a chance
in this game uh he really needed to play
this move queen to b5 which creates a
double attack on the pawn and the bishop
again i would say i wouldn't say impossible
but i would say extremely unlikely without without
without being an advanced player so i think xqc i
found knight c5 which is also a nice move but
now after rook takes sardos to his credit finds
queen to b6 a really really good move um and
now if knight takes bishop you just take on d4
and here again white can play queen b5 and
white is actually i think a little bit better
here because even though black is plus one in
this position you'll notice that um is this
is this better for white or maybe not maybe it's
not actually but after knight to d4 you'll notice
that this knight on b8 is kind of stuck and
these knights on c5 and d4 are very very strong
and white has a really strong rook that can go
down to e7 or maybe eight potentially later on so
even though black is technically up a
pawn white has very good chances here
so uh again if you don't see queen b5 and it's
a very hard move limited time um then there's
not much you can do so now rook c1 or c8 happens
queen to c2 by x you see and at this point it's
already too late because if you go queen b5 again
now after trades i have a very nasty move knight
this is only the beginning
welcome back to patreon three presented by
grip6 i hope you guys are enjoying the show
and a reminder that this is an amazing event
with an amazing codes our participants have
chosen 16 charities to which the donations will
be going to the charity donations from you guys
are matched by chess.com up to a hundred thousand
dollars let's get to 25 000 today can we there's a
banner below the video and also the link in the
chat exclamation mark donate click on that link
and donate when you can as much as you can every
single penny matters so there's no such thing
as too low when it comes to supporting
great causes such as these organizations
that our participants have chosen sqc is still
keeping it mysterious as well as sardoche
but the rest of the players have picked their
charities and i think each and every one of them
are great causes to support so make sure to
support these charities if you would like to
join us in this cause exclamation mark donate in
the chat as well as the banner under the video and
huge chat that by the way on that note to reminder
any currency who donated 500 euros now chess.com
there you go you need to measure that 500 and
let's make jails.com match up to a hundred
thousand dollars thank you so much to each and
every one of you for your donations andrea what's
coming up next is that we are getting set up for
our quarterfinals but tomorrow tomorrow we're
gonna have four clashes four clashes four games
wow it's gonna be a big day tomorrow indeed two of
the quarter-finals of the championship bracket and
two quarter finals from the consolation bracket
i will certainly be very excited and worried and
nervous about the matches of my students nico
versus rubius and pocky facing myth three of them
are my students but the other two matches too rain
wilson's against moist critical and ludwig versus
logic how do you see those championship bracket
quarterfinals uh going down and who do you predict
making it to the semi-finals yeah there are so
many great matchups tomorrow but honestly rain i
think he's a monster i i love moist but i'm scared
for moist against rain and i think it's really
cool nico versus rubius there nico also has a huge
spanish community so i think that's a really great
matchup um and then pokey for smith i think pokey
might school myth a little bit i we did do one
coaching a little bit more with pokey maybe i'm
a bit biased but um i i don't know what do you
think's happening between ludwig and logic though
it's gonna be a very close one i feel like
ludwig has been really consistent preparing
for the tournamental grandmaster robert has cutie
was saying they are spending maybe a bit too much
time together there's a romans brewing in
the background my logic is taking it the
other way he's he is taking it as freestyling
vibing he doesn't want too much preparation but
wants to enjoy the games and so far it has been
working very well for him as well so it's it's
gonna be interesting to see which one will
count more the grind and the lessons almost
every single day on ludwig's side or logic who
has had more chest experience but isn't prefer
isn't preparing much by match for this event yeah
they both have put in a lot of hours and suggests
and we have our next quarter finals match
just about to start reminder here we've
got the winner of group a benji fishy who won
every single match of his and his opponent is
the poker legend himself daniel negrano who was
also close to winning his group he was leading
but then he lost his match against xqc so group
b was a tough one it was almost a last minute
qualification by poki who surprised who surprised
xqc and daniel as well and took down rubius in
her match against rubius but overall we've got
sqc and daniel negrano qualifying from group b
go ahead these participants are very exciting
because i mean benji you've been seeing how much
he's been training with hammer right it's been
crazy training and obviously it's paying off
and then daniel my dad is like his biggest fan
because we are canadian romanian and so is daniel
and my dad always watches his streams and i was
here practicing chess so i don't know who to root
for today oh i didn't know that papa bothers papa
wattas has been rooting for daniel the whole time
number one fan of danielle and danielle by the way
is streaming so you guys can check out his stream
too we will be definitely listening in while
benji usually doesn't stream during the games but
his coach might be his coach grandmaster young
vic hammer often hosts watch parties and they
prepare for the match every day i wonder if
if there will be any changes or surprises
when it comes to the opening repertoire of benji
he usually goes for for a d4 opening nowadays i
feel like he's switching a little bit to those he
started out with the english opening which is not
that common on beginner level yeah honestly
i think with hammer's prep benji already has
more opening expertise than i do i mean he has
had so many prepared lines it was pretty great
he's certainly picking up on all the theoretical
knowledge from grandmaster hammer's side for those
of you who may not know that name grandmaster
you will be hammer is a former second of the
world champion magnus carlsen and he is working
now with benji to prepare him for the tournament
as on the other side we've got dania who also
has taken lessons from none other than gm hikaru
and gotham chess and i myself uh chimed in a
little bit because i felt too bad that two of
my students were out preparing danielle
he complained that i prepared to poke
and rubios for their matches so i helped him since
although maybe it wasn't good enough for her help
because the match against xqc didn't go the way
we planned it yeah excuse me killed that match
well hey i see oh okay the game has
started be right here okay there we go
all right so does benji typically play this
g3 setup i can't tell this is new something
hammer has prepared he does i was i was pulling um
these awkward faces apologies to everybody because
i downloaded an extension today that screams at me
every time i there's no move on the board within
the next two seconds uh hikaru and gotham
chest start screaming at you to make a move
so it's it's currently on in my browser
and then i started listening to hikaru
saying move just move just make a move
and i was wondering is this part of our
broadcast but then i realized no no
anna you you are again moving booming
extension but it's a great one it's a great
extension just don't use it during broadcast as
far as the g3 setup goes yes benji does like the
fiance setup and play for the catalan structure
in this case so started that with english now
it's more of a catalan that he's aiming for but
we could transpose to even e4 openings if benji
pushes the pawn to e4 later that could be more
like a sicilian dragon or a night or daniel does
play the sicilian with the black pieces against e4
yeah let's be comfortable i i was gonna ask i've
never seen someone who plays a neck pillow while
streaming and playing chess i think that's a
pretty good idea true it's a new thing for me but
i i definitely would need it sometimes
and i'm like oh this is this is too stiff
and yeah whoa okay i can make it more cozy a trade
on c6 what do you think of this andrea after bish
after b takes c6 the bishop is pointing at the
c6 bomb but the queen is guarding it from d7
yeah he he took very fast i was a little bit
questionable about daniel's queen b7 move and
normally you don't want to block your bishop so
early but i don't think taking was very good for
benji because it brings the pawns together and
when i play the sicilian and sometimes we can
use the a6 or the b7 square in this case but so
comfortable play for white what do you think anna
i think it's comfortable but it's also gonna
be all right for black if he if he now speeds
up with the development i think g6 bishop
g7 crossover kingside would be a way to go
bishop b7 is logical too to guard the pawn
and maybe later push c5 yeah both will be
on shadow play here i was curious why do
you think he played queen d7 so early on
good question um in that structure of if we go
back just a few moves where he decided to play
just trying to defend yes the knight was hanging
but you're right that usually the queen goes to
c7 or b6 those are more natural squares
because the queen on d7 is blocking the
bishop but overall i think it worked out
well for daniel because after the trade
the b pawn is now on c6 so the bishop does have
the b7 square i think his development will be
all right if he goes for g6 bishop to g7 on the
other flank or pushing the e pawn and bishop e7
yeah now he has no issue blocking his bishop
so far i always i don't really like to play
these double fiance positions because i feel like
they're they're just so repetitive and there's not
much happening but on the right side you don't
spend too much time wearing in your opening
and it's a very solid setup a classical approach
i think if banjo pushes later the pawn to e4 he
will be expanding even further in the center c5 by
daniel i do like that move to offer the trade of
bishops let's see if banji will take it or perhaps
push e4 to block the diagonal but overall now
the light squared bishop of black is a lot more
active since the diagonal is open yeah and he's
doing the right thing because you normally want
to trade the bishop that's defending the king here
so this fianchetto bishop is more important
than this one since we can castle king side
there's a nice move c5 i like it a lot and i'm
wondering if we're gonna see e4 instead of e4
knight to d5 that's an interesting response to
to trade on the d5 square i wonder if danielle
will capture that knight with either his knight
or the bishop usually when there's a choice you
take first with the knight and then after bishop
takes d5 you could have taken the bishop two but
pawn takes d5 now means that the light squared
bishops will not be traded and i think it's time
to develop the king's side so let's see if daniel
is on the same page and pushes g6 to friend cato
the other bishop make it to g7 and castle kingside
gosling here i think is becoming urgent and so
he goes for g6 yeah it's a very interesting
position they traded all their miners except
the bishop pair um i think benji might be able
to get a little bit of space in the center but
these bishops these or whenever i mean if they
keep the bishops it could be a little bit rash
i wonder how it's going to unravel from here i'm
curious how will benji follow up this plan now
with the pawn structure being somewhat different
to the usual setups that he goes for and uh now
that he can't really go for b3 bishop d2 or at
least it wouldn't be the same to try to fianchetto
yeah bishop g7 of course yes now you can no longer
follow the double fianchetto i mean maybe he could
prepare it with rook b1 but his bishop has a
lot of good scores on this diagonal as well
i agree and then just taking his
time to come up with the right setup
i think it's it's definitely a key moment because
you need to decide where do you want to place this
c1 bishop will you try to place it on the long
diagonal bishop d2 bishop c3 would be an option
for that too or bishop f4 to keep it on the
h61 diagonal but now after bishop g7 um the
b2 pawn two is targeted i think this bishop will
be very powerful on the long diagonals there was
i was leaning toward bishop d2 bishop c3 to
try to challenge this bishop and not let it be
a power piece yeah here i mean typically okay
and he plays i was going to say well black has
a really strong bishop maybe he could try to trade
it on h6 and he is going for that which is always
so annoying when i play the fiance bishop on
the king side i don't like the bishop h6 lines
i agree with you and let's listen a bit daniel if
he's any worried about those bishop trades or not
get situated get safe and then i think i
gotta push this epon at some point right
that e point what's this now okay i'm not going to
take so he's trying to come here with the queen
nope i'm not going to let
that happen so we are going to
protect this square even more with this and then
we trade here but our king is still protected
so far i'm playing well i haven't
made any mistakes as far as i know
like i've made mistakes i'm sure but like
for my game and where it's at happy with
the start so far now you just got to focus
he takes ends to take okay now what do we
do now what do we do i don't really know but
we seem safe right okay what's that now he's
coming to press that pressure that pawn okay so
he could on facant me if i push up there twice
so he's coming well what's that going to do
anything that's an important detail if we bring
our board back andrea the umpire son rule a
reminder to our viewers engaged they haven't
heard of that strange thing called amphison
that it's a thing it doesn't happen too often but
if you push your phone two squares and there's
this d5 phone that could jump capture you it
captures in passing on vassan it takes on e6
and that would attack the queen as well as opens
up the long diagonals so if you capture the pawn
with the queen your b7 bishop falls yes i learned
when we uh hosted block champs we forgot to teach
one of our participants what it was and he was
very shocked when the pawn took not now as it
normally does so i'm glad he's aware of it yeah um
it can look like a glitch because you have a pod
on e5 and suddenly it's gone yeah is a special
rule has it can only happen though if the pawn
jumps two squares jumps across the capture square
of the other pawn an ampersand is only possible
straight away right after the move was played you
cannot make it a move later then it's already not
available it's going to be illegal to try to
capture the pronunciation v8 i like and then
what do you think for sure because you can carry
it a lot it's very nice the two rooks like you
said there was a lot of tactics and he couldn't
push and he needs to break through because his
bishop would be hanging and now he defended both
squares so eventually maybe he can push that pawn
the only issue with his unpleasant idea that he
sees that there will be another sound that's good
but the next thing to see that after you push
the e pawn the d6 pawn becomes more vulnerable
so even if he's not losing the bishop on b7
e5 d takes e6 the d6 pawn uh could be an issue
and it's happening let's see if angie captures the
pawn or not so he has a choice you don't have to
do the opposite capture you have a choice but only
now only here and now if banji plays anything else
he can no longer do it and he does he does
take the pawn meaning that now daniel has to
be careful to remember that the d6 pawn has become
exposed now through the d5 where benji's queen and
rook are lined up so he has to take back on e6
little rook to guard the pawn yeah i don't think
it's too bad if he takes with the rook i mean
luckily maybe he could unpin his queen and since
the queen is attacking the pawn first but it is a
backwards pawn and it is a big weakness for daniel
i think he did the right thing with rook takes
e6 he must have seen this coming so i think he
calculated that this will happen and by by trading
the d5 pawn at least there's no longer upon
that suffocating your pieces that yes it was
annoying taking a lot of space away from black's
pieces so overall i think this was a good idea to
free black's pieces and we're going to see a heavy
psm game only rooks and queens on the board yeah
it's going to be they traded very quickly in this
game oh but benji does not want to trade he wants
to leave the bishops on the board yeah what do you
think about his move i think it's a tricky one i
think i see what he wants i think he spotted that
the rook on e6 and the queen on d7 are on the same
diagonal and bishop to h3 could win one of those
pieces wow you think he's going for the tactics
i think so i think he's very sharp that one
would that'd be impressive i think of that trick
i i feel like he's setting it up because he blocks
the long diagonal so after bishop h3 queen c6 will
no longer be attacking anything around the king
without this so if he had moved bishop to h3 a
move earlier if we if we just show for a moment um
it wouldn't have been that powerful first of
all um queen to c6 threatens checkmate on h1
or g3 if the bishop moves away and even f5 could
have happened um i think it's happening actually
andrew we need to go back check it out go go don't
do it because it's how he plays it bishop wow
benji is very sharp he had a slim which i think
it was interesting to kind of put this pawn in the
center create a potential weakness and go for this
but daniel didn't see it he did not see it and he
was clearly showing signs of shock he grabbed his
head and he missed this idea we need to see now
how will he try to save the situation the rook
will be lost you cannot move it because then it's
even worse and then his pawn is gonna be hanging
he's gonna have to be doing a lot of defending
yeah just get max value and take the pawn oh no
i can't take the pawn because then he just takes
off oh good job dude you really got me
good with this i don't know i don't know
i've never heard that phrase
benji i did not see he's right though he needs to
get max value for the road up my rook and queen
good job he's good all right
we are definitely behind
[ __ ] but we're not out we're not gonna quit
hm do our best this
i'll have to look at it later okay
and this is an obvious move here
so he's up two points i got one pawn back
so listen it's not the end of the race
he lost a piece but what do i do now i think
come up the left side with the pawns and the king
he's so well protected
all right
looks like we're coming for a battle shortly
f3 is a great move by benji to
strengthen the central pawn on e4
yes very solid it doesn't want to give daniel
any counter play here and now g5 by daniel to
try to tear those phones apart i think he is
trying to push at some point for now it's making
it's making the structure a bit more fixed
i wonder if he actually wants to push g4 or
it's simply making his king side feel safer it's
tough to play this position because he did lose
the rook on e6 at the same time the position is
still very closed and rooks love open files so
banji will need to try to open up the position
yeah that's very true i mean he's a material but
the plan for white to break through isn't clear
like i i think daniel can just kind of wait
i agree with you and i wonder if this is
what he's explaining he really is truly
in the midst of his thought process and going
here and there explaining it to his audience
queen to c2 by benji let's listen in i'm
curious if that's what daddy i was talking about
g6 by moving your pawn up attack
attack i think i need to move my
king where does my king go in a more
protected spot yeah king's gotta go
here i wanna say oh wait yeah i know here's
fine oh no is it fine i think back actually
not sure clearly
do not know now that pawn is vault no it's not
vulnerable because my queen's protecting it
i think i expect the pawn push from him soon
with that e5 square i can take back with
my pawn all right he's breaking up my chain
hmm if we bring our analysis back for a moment
there are possibly tactics in this position
because of the king stepping away it was an
interesting decision by daniel i didn't know if
it was needed but now he is taking on f4 and the
g file is opening up so actually his move becomes
even stronger now that the king is on f8 the g5 is
available for black's pieces and i was wondering
if he could have taken on e4 but he plays queen to
g7 instead a lot more logical king f2 and will we
see will we see a pawn sacrifice because if you
push f5 and white takes it queen to g2 would be
check me wow i wonder if he will try to do it dad
has been talking about f5 for the last five moves
or like yeah and it was always wrong but it's
finally finally it's moments time to shine here
f5 would be very very nice okay it's logical
very logical too yeah attacking f4 threatening
queen age for check i think daniel is back in
the game because of the activity of his queen
and how this bishop on c6 can become the hero of
the story if he finds the right moment to push f5
yeah this pawn structure is so fragile i
mean he has to keep his queen and his rook
to defend everything i don't even know what
he can bring in to defend these dark squares
not an easy one for benji if he wants to hold on
to the pawn on f4 he will need to protect it with
a move like queen to d2 yep and then the pawn will
be hanging on e4 which is is even more dangerous
i i honestly i'm not sure what's the best defense
here for white i feel like you will need to give
up the f4 pawn and try to bring your queen to
the king side let's save it like and queen f3
afterwards but you are giving up a lot of pawns um
and it's never an easy decision to take because of
course you always want to try to defend everything
that's hanging in this case i think banji needs to
think of damage control and realize that if he
wants to hold on to the f4 pawn perhaps he's
losing more than the pawn yeah this this got so
tricky i mean currently it's a dead draw but even
like the solid defense that you put i think the
okay they would still be losing the e4 pawn here
he plays queen 2d2 and this is a moment where
where black could take awning for with the bishop
yes threaten queen f3 or queen to g2 um maybe in
that position white should give up the rook for
the bishop rook takes 36 and then at least he can
take the d6 phone too both kings will be exposed
yeah this i don't even know let's play let's
look at this position here um both both sides can
really check anywhere they want but i don't think
i don't think white has a specific plan here this
this would be this would be perhaps still anyone's
game i need to happen it may have been drawn
all right it may happen because daniel has
taken on e4 so now it's up to benji whether he
realizes the danger of this light squared bishop
and gives up his rook for the bishop will he do it
or will he try to defend by playing i don't know
rook g1 looks like it could defend something but
then queen f3 and bishop discovered czech
i think his only move is to give up wow
will he see it he's got two minutes two
minutes left to decide about that sacrifice
if he doesn't do it i think his king will be
checkmated in a few moves it is option defense
wow he started with some very sharp tactics but
it's just this one move and from there the game
took a turn now it'd be very interesting to go
into the the end game with just rook and queen
i wonder if it will come to that conclusion
because any other attempt i feel like will be
way too dangerous for the king again the threats
of black are the ones marked by andrea queen f3
and queen g2 and then a discovery check on the
e file you could look at so if white tries to
defend mate here then queen f3 and now this is
the discovery attack you were talking about anna
indeed and after king to e1 it's gonna be
made almost wherever the bishop goes bishop
d3 perhaps he's the most precise just to finish
the game on the spot but the king can't brutal
okay so he literally has no choice but to stack
let's see oh my god he's under a minute even with
if he does sack going to an end game with equal
material but this big time disadvantage it's going
to be very hard for him to play under pressure
and he played it he played it rook takes e4 by
benji fishy with one minute left on the clock
he plays the only move that can save his king
and now after rook takes e4 the queen can take the
d pawn and suddenly both kings will be vulnerable
yeah this is such a weird position
i mean black is trying to take on f4
white could just check and try to potentially
escape it's gonna be very interesting all right
oh they played it it's happening it's
happening rook takes c4 queen takes d6
let's see where danya goes with the
king he chooses the g7 square oh
the queen trade if banjo wants he could trade
with queen d7 am i seeing i must have been
this the rookie one must have not worked oh
yeah because rook takes you were right that
didn't look no no it didn't work it didn't work it
looked like about this gambit but it wasn't a full
one because of rick takes there for winning the
rogue but the the rook trade rook shade not but
the queen trade is happening on d7 so queen d7 was
played by benji trade on d7 and king g6 king f3
oh wow from a position where white was about to be
mated benji realized he had to give the material
back and we are seeing currently a rook end game
with equal material benji is taking the a7 pawn so
he does have now an extra pawn can dania fight
back attack maybe the h pawn uh or maybe maybe
activate his king but the problem with activating
the king is that the h7 pawn two will be hanging
wow and both players know the stats here you
always want to bring the rooks behind the pawns
what daniel is doing but i mean he has this
password i don't think he'll be able to stop
it after king to g3 h5 a4 is a very logical
decision to run with the passport but that
creates a weakness in the structure the b3 pawn
and danielle immediately spots it attacks it with
rook to b1 i'm expecting rook b7 by benji no he
plays rookies attacking it but he get the check
check it's taken with the check unfortunately for
benji he may not have seen that he was going to
be captured with a check and now dania could
attack both the a and f phones with root b4
oh my god but it's still well according to
evaluation still draw here oh i think it may
be cool but it doesn't matter but it doesn't
eat anyone's game it's not anyone's game
rook end games are my least
favorite they're so tricky
are they okay he's going all right he's not
defending his f4 pawn he's trying to push
danya takes first and f4 and i think now he will
go to the a fight to stop the passport rook to a4
that's my prediction he has to
stop that pawn before it's too late
so rook a4 a7 and then there's no way that white
can defend this a8 square without moving his rook
so can't promote just yet rookie four played by
daniel and a7 immediately by benji now c4 so the
point is that with this defense the tara shrook
we call it this a4 rook for black it means that
you can't move the rook away from the seventh
rank because our our rook is well positioned
to capture the pawn as soon as you try to support
the promotions grab it rook c8 the pawn on a7 will
drop so it's a great great resource that daniel
has found it's exactly how it's written in the
end game textbooks and he's pushing his his past
pawn his upper pawn and he could also try to bring
his king closer or push the f pawn i think benji
should be able to hold it under i don't circumvent
it he has taken a beautiful game so far wow he
takes a c4 because if danielle ever gonna take
the rook on c4 the phone could have promoted
so very nice tactic on what they found by benji
simplifying the position the less pawns the better
in this rook end game for the defense now this f
pawn shouldn't be winning but danya can try and
i think on this level you still need to be very
careful rook czech king coming closer white has
to defend precisely what do you think is there any
plan where black can try to use their extra pawn
here to win if you trade and you plan to break
yeah if you traded rooks in the right moment on
the right spot for instance that would be one
of the dangers the king and poland game funnily
enough f and h pawns in rook and games can also
be drawn with that white having an age pawn
but those are very specific positions and i
don't think uh we're gonna get to see that h3 i
feel like benji is sammy setting up a stalemate
yeah he's trying i don't know he could have
forced it with a rook check he's escaped though
king back to g3 i wonder if daniel will
start bringing his king he plays rook to e5
okay so now what maybe king g5 trying to advance
running a check but even okay he's preventing it
let's listen to him and what he thinks about
this rookhand game and he's winning chances
trade the rook and then run the pawn up
somehow he's got 18 seconds tick-tock baby
oh wow that was not good from him oh
is it maybe it is good hold on oh my
god i think we need our board back through the
drawers oh my god he just had to take the rook
taking the rook here but it was it was going to
be another end game you take this pawn and even if
black wins h4 it would have been
a draw but now black is winning
this is a winning king and pawning game and i
think daniel knows it we shall see his king and
technique but i think he knows it that
banji made a mistake allowing the rook
trade the way it happened in the game
is exactly what he should have prevented
yeah i mean the draw was like a slip of his
fingers but now this is why when my dad trained
me always taught me that end games matter most
important at beginner level because if you know
how to trade everything you know your end game
is better but here daniel did not know his end
games well i guess both sides banji banjo didn't
know that's true yourself with the rook train
no one knew their end game well now this is a
winning king and born in game very simply winning
by pushing the pawn to f2 but daniel may have
gotten scared of a ghost stalemate coming back
we do it again yeah he could hopefully he doesn't
want to trade his f1 for the h pawn that would
that would be a disaster in this way it's fine
if you don't lose your f1 then it's fine wow
so all right here we go again here we go
again and now both the age and f phones
are running so white cannot prevent the
promotion of both pawns daniel could claim
two queens if he wants he can promote both
of those pawns and give a checkmate with two
queens on the board and why not have to check f1
queen next move let's look at the game what a game
let's listen to daniel what he says two
queens nice and easy and then we walk him back
oh baby doll so calm we got
him people we done did it
up one with black too
i love his phrases he's like a nice dad at
a barbecue or something with the first game
dean eggs is on the board whoo baby
doll how the hell did i do that
winning the first game of his quarterfinals
against the favorite one would have thought benji
fishy won all of his matches in the group stage
and now he will be in a must-win situation when we
return for the second game andra your thoughts on
this roller coaster and what happened with benji
first winning on exchange but then danielle
fighting back with that kingside attack it was
honestly such a high level game it was a beautiful
game like down in exchange he managed to get the
king attack win this end game like doesn't look
like a pogchamp game to me what are you thinking
very high level fight with both of them playing i
think really precisely there were a few mistakes
and the final one being benji allowing the rook
trade in a way that the king and opponent game was
unfortunately for him a theoretical loss
so maybe his coach will talk to him more
about king and phone and games too we're gonna
listen to his stream while we take a short break
pogchamps three presented by grip six we will be
back in a moment um and here in this position he
did have the opportunity to exchange after which
it would have been a draw but instead he chose
to do the exchange under unfavorable circumstances
because here black has this extra pawn and there's
nothing you can do to stop that pawn from
going up the board and becoming a new queen
is something like king g2 a lot
better where he pushed the pawn um
i mean anything is really better than what he
did uh but the plan we were studying was that
he could try and get his rooks together uh
working towards this pawn on d6 so that was
like he the reason benji pushed this pawn forward
was because he wasn't sure what to do next but one
of the things he could have done was putting
pressure down down towards the the black pawn
can you call benji i'm not calling benji
but i will say that i'll send him a message
do
are you benji's coach yes so i've been
coaching benji every single day uh for the last
month and uh a half honestly a month and a
half we've been working now and benji has made
tremendous tremendous progress uh and now
next game he's gonna play the french opening
and if you want to know how benji is going to
play this french opening you can actually check
it out on my youtube channel because i i published
there a video on on how benji will play with the
with the black pieces it's uh benji's favorite
opening to play the french honestly he prefers
being black to being white so there's no reason
to give up just yet he will get another chance
don't spoil for daniel well if daniel
has seen it then you know good for him
he's done his research but i i think and this
is my opinion i think benji's opening is so good
that even if daniel has watched uh our
videos our coaching every every coaching
session i've had with benji i i've streamed on
my channel so anyone can go into my video library
and watch the lessons we've had including the
lesson on the french which is what benji will uh
we'll we'll go for now revealing
your proteges openings what are you
the saint louis chess club no i i i'm just
saying there's there's good there's a good
opening for beginners hey me again luscious larry
leather browns sweaty heavy pocky leather wow
mom wait don't kiss him i'm your son
i'm here from the future if you kiss
him i won't exist so please hey i love your
belt is that what you wear in the future
rad totally what my grip 6 belt i know
right i love this no flailing flaps bulging
buckles they're hideous holes and with
a lifetime guarantee you really can't go
whether it's the grip six belts or the chest that
you are aiming to get we hope that you already
visited the website at go dot chess dot com slash
grip six but big news an update from grip six is
that they have restocked their chess wallets as
well so if you want to get the chest wallet that
was previously sold out they now have another 50
units added to their stock at this time make sure
to take advantage of it and use the code pogchamps
20 to get 20 percent off again it's go.js.com
grip6 well anna that was a very exciting game do
you think what are the chances we go into a sudden
death i think the chances are still pretty good
for benji from what we have heard from his coach
grandmaster joel vic hammer is that benji actually
prefers to play with the black pieces that he
loves the french defense so much i fully agree and
approve that he likes to play a lot that system
and now he will have a chance because danielle
does play e4 with the white pieces so we're gonna
see a french defense that's almost guaranteed yeah
i always love when coach hammer chimes in he helps
my sister a little bit with her french defense
and it definitely paid off but i always tell her
to stop playing it because here we struggle but
with hammer's help i i think the french is good
and i think we have a lift off if we update
our board daniel negrano with the white pieces
he won his first game so benji isn't a must-win
situation they are blitzing out the initial moves
it was this capture on move three that uh benji
has gone for taking on e4 and then developing the
knights they're blitzing out these moves both of
them said you know they're very prepared very well
prepared indeed andrea this is a theoretical line
i'm impressed grandmasters played this park shows
participants play this they all know exactly
what's the trending move was the trending line
to go for bishop to g5 pins the knight on f6 the
idea is that the bishop cannot be taken because
that would have been a bonus gambit too many
voters can't beat no both says gambit so yeah
they sure like their bishop positions once again
almost i guess we still have a knight here but
benji has the bishop pair the hammer loves
bishop pear i also know that one as well
exactly i was gonna say that on on this account i
think i i'm thinking that the trade after bishop
takes bishop takes i do like that daniel is going
for it very confidently and playing queen d3 so
he did give up the pair of bishops but he does
have more space and he's ahead in development i
was even wondering whether he wanted to castle
queenside after queen d3 it would have been an
interesting choice maybe not the best but
it would have been definitely an aggressive
one he doesn't need to be aggressive though the
match situation is again that banji has to win
if he doesn't win this game there's no tie breaker
banji will be eliminated from the tournament
and doesn't the french tend to get into drawing
positions and he he can't afford a drawing a
draw either and john what are you saying about the
phrase i mean i don't know that's what i've heard
but maybe you've got a point maybe a bias may
have a point but this position is not symmetrical
the exchange variation would have been perhaps
then um a better choice for the the drewish
lines but i i like that daniel is going for
something that's ambitious i think it's very
difficult to play for a draw even if you know that
that's a good result for you to play on purpose
in a way that you just try to trade and enter a
symmetrical or drawish position is very difficult
at pogchamps level even more so a super tournament
i think grandmasters have a repertoire where if
you need a draw you play your more solid lines but
at park jumps even the armageddon for tiebreakers
i think rain wilson had a good point about it
that draw odds for black is isn't really an
advantage because there are barely any draws in
this tournament yeah i totally agree so so here
what how do you think benji is gonna develop i
mean one interesting thing is it kind of looks
like he could transpose into maybe fianchetto
development okay sticking out his queen but i was
gonna ask where do you suggest taking out the c8
bishop that's what i don't like about the french
where you take that guy out i don't understand
it's always the problem piece in the french you
are right andra and again it's similar because
this bishop on e4 is very annoying if you place
the black bishop on d7 the b7 pawn will
be hanging so yeah i mean just compare it
compare this bishop to this bishop this is why
i tell alex not to play the french but whatever
but what about not developing it for now because
daniel is allowing the trade on e5 so banji could
win a pawn by capturing the knight on
e5 pawn takes back and queen takes e5 i
wonder if daniel had seen this let's listen
in if he's giving up that pawn on purpose
for now we will not know
let's see if he realizes that
straight on e5 is push potential issue it's the
f5 i'm not sure if i'm supposed to push f4 g4
after f4 would strengthen the night but he
may have had to do it to move earlier if
banji realizes that he can take taking his time
at this position understandably so oh and we got
it yeah you didn't question what queen d6 was
doing he did not he pushed c3 to strengthen the
d4 pawn and i wonder what will be his reaction
now when benji takes the opponent from fighting
queen troy is coming okay so a pretty simplified
position now no if he trades if he doesn't i
don't know he did not okay so so in that case i
think i pawn push put more pressure on him yeah
free up the space for my rook to come out
and play yeah he didn't even react to the fun
okay he knows good thing i put that
pawn on c3 that really helped a lot
because if i didn't then i'd be vulnerable
let's bring her back because it it doesn't
look like danielle likes the position i i think
you're gonna need he didn't care about that
it may be the fact that he absolutely likes
gambits at chess many of his openings initially
for park gems ii and pre-park gyms wear gambits
he loves the danish gambit he learned the smiths
more again with from hikaru and he also learned a
couple of gambits with the black pieces i wonder
is it because his intuition is saying danielle you
should have enough conversation your pieces are
active and you have this initiative going on the
king side so maybe even though he didn't realize
that he lost a pawn during those trades on e5
he it's true that he is ahead in development and
the c8 bishop is still difficult to get out of
the the back rank you cannot push the big phone
do you think he likes these gametes because
he's a poker player because he's a gambler
i'm not sure we'll need to ask him we'll need to
ask him in the interview if he chose gambits for
that reason but i do know that he loves aggressive
attacking chess so he doesn't mind giving up a
pawn or two if it means that he's gonna have the
upper hand and initiative and whether it was on
purpose or not that's what is happening partially
that he is trying to attack on the king's side by
black is still struggling to develop the only
issue that he has pushed the f pawn that now
for instance black could play bishop to d7 and the
b7 pawn is no longer hanging because of queen b6
check picking up the bishop on b7 yeah he kind of
created a weakness on this diagonal which he had
the right ideas trying to get space put his pawns
on black because we have the light squared bishops
but i do not like the diagonal his kings well i
guess black is kind of in the same situation now
interesting that banji moved to g7 i guess he
didn't like if the white queen appears on 86
yeah which which can be scary but i mean without
the dark square bishop there's no way that white
can actually ever come to g7 he's got a point
though that if white manages to bring the rook
over to the king size through the third rank rook
to d3 or rook f3 and then swing over to the h5
it could be troublesome that kingside attack that
could lead to checkmate yeah that was his plan he
pushed f4 with the idea for a rook lift i think so
too you're right that this is very dangerous here
even if he loses a second bomb because now
after queen b6 check if the king moves to age
1 you can take on b2 as well but i'm worried
that even though black will be two pawns up
again there is some initiative on the king side
already and as soon as the rooks will appear
in the attack i think in a on a practical level
it's not easy rook to d4 though is a boundary
because the rook is pinned and the
white the white rook will not be able to
i'm not gonna lie i stared at
this i was like but after it takes
time how is it winning it was i didn't
see the queen but i see it now i see it
oh good job all right don't quit don't quit
keep playing you've got some
stuff happening in this reaction
but it wouldn't have been a day hosted by andrea
if we don't see him right andra it's it's
all for you it's all in honor of you i
why would i do that all right my brain is melted
looks like most like an armageddon but you know
what don't quit that was just really not
a didn't move his pep talk is bad it is
true maybe like you get tilt like in poker you
get tilt when something goes bad and then here
you know i lose my queen and i'm like oh
duh you just take his bishop i'm on tilt
now where does his bishop go
it goes wherever it wants to go
okay i was saying so true it's so true saying
let's bring the board back for a moment to just
take in what happened rook to d4 was a blunder if
we roll back a few moves that's when we started
screaming and we couldn't actually vocalize what
went wrong e5 is a winning move that was spotted
instantly by banji the bishop is attacking the
queen and the pawn is targeting the rook you will
lose either your queen or the rook you cannot
save both pieces i have to say though the way
i really respect how his mentality like
when i get tilted it does not end well but
he's doing so well just pep talking himself he
recognizes that he's keeping himself positive
he's trying his best but the position is gonna
be very rough to try to hold when it comes to
having a queen down he doesn't even have a piece
for it so it's a queen or for no material he does
have some activity but i think benji will go for
the trades rook d8 the d4 rook is still pinned
i mean i've come back from a few solid games
after a whole queen i dropped but i mean luckily
for this we'll get a very exciting blitz game
exactly if benji wins this game and it seems to be
the way the game is going then there will be
a tiebreaker of a sudden death blitz game five
minutes no increment yeah piano and unfinished
king there uh queen's coming for the back rank
so who do you think's d4 we'll have
the upper hand in the blitz playoff
i'm not sure because i thought this match
was going very well for daniel even this game
until rook d4 i thought white had it under
control they were saying that he does have
compensation for the pawn even two pawns if he
moved king gage1 or or rook f2 rook ft would
have guarded the b2 pawn but rook d4 unfortunately
was a big blunder so nabanji is back in the match
and he will have some of the psychological
advantage because he is the one who made a
huge comeback from a match situation that was
lost for him that is true yeah well this game is
pretty much over but daniel's gonna play until
the end oh you know anything can happen maybe
i mean at this level i don't think you should be
resigning these positions just yet yeah i always
tell everyone i always tell my all my bookchum
students to to never give up i know this is this
is very desperate and benji is going for the kill
queen takes g2 is the threat checkmate and i think
we're gonna see it on the board but at least
at least he tried as much as he could with that
benji fish is tying the score and we're gonna see
our first sudden death blitz tiebreaker in just a
few moments andra your thoughts on this comeback
i'm very excited honestly anything can happen
in this splits we got a botez gambit daniel had a
huge comeback in both games even when he's losing
he comes back very well but i don't know how
they're going to perform under time pressure
i think we started following another norwegians
game in the meantime that's possibly because
we're going to be tuning into grand master junovic
hammer stream for the next few minutes and then we
are back with the tiebreaker remember this is
it the quarterfinals in the championship record
between benji fishy and daniel negranu going
down the wire five minute sudden death blitz
games until one of them wins see you soon in
a moment functions represented by group six
to the middle this is what we're going for
just solid solid play get both bishops pointing
down the board good control over the middle good
chances to win benji is the better player he
made a mistake in the first white game and
he got punished for it he also freaked out when
he was low on time but he can make the comeback
uh we've practiced the three plus one so
we've practiced uh for this tiebreak situation
unfortunately we practiced before they changed the
rules so instead of a brits game three plus one
uh one second increment per move we're now going
to be playing at five plus nil uh and so benji
is not very comfortable without the increments
i think so that's gonna be a big change for him
uh okay so benji has acknowledged that he got
my message and he has said he will not take this
knight otherwise we're not changing the opening
we were happy with the white opening last time my
main concern right now is pacing pacing is really
difficult especially when you've just played a
10 minute game where you in addition got five
extra seconds per move that was made it's very
different changing into a game without increment
and with less time it's difficult to make that
mental adjustment has benji played a lot of blitz
asks andy uh not a lot but we have specifically
practiced to play um bullet chests and uh three
minute chests to get better at dealing with
stressful situations when you're low on time and
the reason we did that is because we knew that
there could be tie breaks in the knockout stages
and you need to be ready for that so we definitely
trained for the tie breaks but unfortunately
we didn't practice uh five minute games
uh no mike it's not an armageddon
it's not an armageddon it's five minutes for both
players if it's a draw they play another game
it's so hard with no increment
and time becomes way more tactical
yes at tizer which is why you know i wish we
could have practiced the new rules but segavi
negranu might revert to the danish
gambit with a lower time no he you
cannot play the danish gambit against the
french i'm sorry it's just not possible
i i don't care how fond you are of his danish
gambit it's not gonna happen today i'm sorry
benji plays the french defense very solid opening
choice in fact i think everyone starting out in
chess should play the french defense because it
it stops all of these tricky openings in fact
i think it's the safest opening for a beginner
to learn which is why i've made a youtube video
named the safe welcome back to the broadcast of
function 3 presented by grip6 we will have our
first tiebreaker in the championship bracket and
a reminder on the format that this is going to be
a sudden death blitz game five minutes no
increment both players will have five minutes
with no increment and the player who wins will
move on to the semi-finals in case of a draw
we're gonna have a next sudden death blitz games
and the next one and the next one until one of
the players manages to win and qualify to the
semis andra your thoughts on the tiebreaker
after hearing that benji's coach gm hammer said
that benji may not have practiced much of a bliss
yeah amber did say he doesn't play a lot with
increment but honestly i kind of feel like
my prediction is we might get a draw which is fun
the more blitz the better but i i don't know how
much experience um daniel has without increments
i was taking a look at their accounts in terms
of blitz games i'm not sure about whether with
increment or not but danielle does have more
blitz games let's see okay i was going to mention
real quick that danielle has played over 900
blitz games and benji 36 blitz games wow clearly
more experience on daniel's side but maybe maybe
not without increments so let's see how this game
will turn out similar opening as in the first game
benji with the white pieces since he is number
one seated in group a therefore he receives the
white pieces daniel has been a chess fan for very
long but 900 games is a lot of blitz i must say
pretty great very true let's see how benji deals
with this new situation that he needs to play a
blitz tiebreaker with absolutely no increment
so there's there's zero increment it's not the
same when it comes to time pressure with the the
rapid format e5 here by daniel what do you think
of this push andrea um well before e5 i was gonna
say he fixed his mistake because in the previous
game he played queen d7 which blocked his bishop
oh i guess this knight before line's actually
a little bit annoying but he played differently
from the first game because he analyzed his games
it's true that he learned from that uh
slightly misplaced queen on d7 but now it's
nice b5 especially since he pushed e5 to chase
that away yeah i think we needed like an a6 or
something i i'm not sure but he can still yeah
indeed he can still go for it he can still push
a6 and then the knight has to go to a3 since
this other knight is occupying the c3 square
yup he just took his square knight on the rim it i
always say is slim but it's dim i just learned uh
recently actually i think both are cute both are
adorable and both certainly mean that it's not the
best not the coolest something has to be played
there's so many words that work whatever okay
we need to see how daniel will develop his
pieces i think bishop b7 is a very logical
move and he's ready to castle next the only
issue with his spawn structure is that the d6
pawn is a backward pawn and it can be a future
target as well as the d5 square is a weakness
so overall even though banjo's knight is on the
edge of the board if he brings it back through a
night maneuver like knight to c to knight e3 then
knight d5 he would have a better position so let's
see if he will if he'll realize that he shouldn't
leave the knight on a3 and maneuver it back toward
the middle of the board yeah that maneuver would
be beautiful to see which makes a lot of sense
because he doesn't really have any other squares
and normally you're suggesting for benji earlier
in the last game which is e4 pawn but here do you
still think he should be pushing in the center
i think for now it's great that the bishop has
an open diagonal and puts so much pressure on
black's pieces so i think it's fine to not
push e4 since he still has his c4 pawn two
guarding the d5 square knight to g4 by daniel
i was curious if he was gonna move the queen
away because he has to get that bishop out of
the background somehow yep same problem as last
time maybe he'll do the same development on b7
but i'm not sure his knight g4 move i i mean it
gets kicked away in one move and then you have
to retreat but okay he didn't push h3 anyway
let's listen him with him and see if he sees
the knight form that is being threatened on b6
freaking face and i hate it all right we're
going back i'm getting rid of that see that's
stupid right anytime you do that you know you
don't know what you're doing but that's okay
i need it i need to make a move now he moves here
i'll move back no but benji didn't see it either
did he oh no oh oh um back to our board we need
to show this nobody saw it all right that was a
blind spot that was a blind spot after knight to
d5 white was threatening knight b6 attacking the
queen and the rook so you would be winning one
of those pieces uh danielle was annoyed by the
knight on d5 so he dropped the knight back
to a sixth attack it and benji immediately
took the bishop on e7 a strange decision but he
must have had his eyes on that bishop priorly
yeah which i don't know why he was so eager to
trade his bishop because now daniel's actually
unraveled a little bit he opened up the diagonal
for his bishop that bishop was kind of blocked
by its own pawns anyways so and that knight
was pretty strong in the center to begin with
i agree with you that it's a strange decision
but it's a time pressure yeah exactly banji is
not used to it so i think the fact that he wants
to find quick moves is already great he's up on
time so that was a conscious decision and maybe
take take number two if we refresh our board he
made it to d5 with his knight he made it to
d5 with his knight and now daniel takes it
um if we just go back one move
andrea i was curious if we were gonna
you're doing amazing you're doing
amazing we didn't have a second
chance at that night for because it was
traded danielle took the knight on d5
okay and this is the current position yes we are
here right with you anna not one step behind right
here okay we've got this we've got this guarding
on a backward spawn like you were mentioning
earlier and that's an issue because how do you
guard that pawn the bishop is in the way so rook
2d8 will not defend the pawn i wonder if daniel
will try to go for some kind of a counter attack
bishop g4 to try to detect the e to pawn or take
on c4 look at moves like knight b4 any any threats
or jumps that he can go for with the knight knight
to be for he plays indeed i don't know if it's
good but it looks like it does something yeah now
i mean after this both these pieces will be under
attack he has to trade then we have the strong
rook on d6 attacking the bishop attacking the pawn
this pawn taking because of the bishop i mean this
position is looking pretty good for benji he has
won the pawn and yes you're right that now with
the rook on d6 d7 bishop hanging later the a6 pawn
two could be um in trouble as well as the e5 pawn
so it's it's more than the d6 pawn it feels like
benji will win at least one more point and he's up
on time there's no increment the reminder that one
minute 23 seconds is all that dania has if he
runs out of time he loses the game yup and now
yeah benji could clearly even though he was less
experienced he has been performing very well f6 i
think is a good practical decision to try to mess
things up but banji reacts with bishop c3 pointing
out that the knight on b4 doesn't have too
many squares knight to c2 attacking the rook c1
c4 yeah e4 was also a threat as you were pointing
out to cut the bishop uh from the defense of the
knight on c2 knight to a3 spotted by danny and
he plays it oh my goodness he's seen everything
that's crazy he does spot tactical patterns very
quickly benjamin might have missed the night fork
earlier but now he sees it all he sees it all and
daniel is giving up the knight on c4 no choice
yeah if he ran to b1 we still had e4 wow he's
spotting these so fast i feel like he could have
tried to go back to c2 because at least it was
gonna attack the bishop but now this is gonna be
a piece of a piece up for benji he can also take
the pawn on a6 he decides rook to d5 instead
he's up on the clock and off with a full piece yup
daniel's down to under one minute no increments so
this thing yeah so if he takes
here we can take with a check or
we could save this bishop yes they traded
in the dark side in a funny way wow
still an extra piece for benji and he's capturing
the pawn too with the rook he knows that
simplifying the position is good for him because
of having an extra bishop in this endgame upper
bishop and upper pawn it's looking very difficult
for danielle with only 33 seconds on the clock
yeah benji is a monster doing him no counter play
keeping his pawn in the center making another pass
one here he didn't even consider taking on f5
that would have dropped the beef the d5 bishop
he doesn't blunder and he has 23 seconds i mean
there's somebody winning plans for white here
let's see if banji can keep up this excellent
speed and quality of moves because he has been
playing very precisely apart from that one missed
chance of the night fork he has done a really good
job in this blitz game and he hasn't played many
blitz games we know from his coach that this is
exactly what they prepared for i can just imagine
hammer right now just glowing with pride excellent
choice again to just go for creating an a passport
and push it he can't push it right now because
he's thinking he gives the check defend his rook
now he can push but he's also going on time he
started thinking he's down to 30 seconds and he
has to see that he can push a6 and then run a7
a8 that will be checkmate promoting with
checkmate yep i was gonna say maybe he was
thinking like if there was a sack on the bishop
and they would push a7 this would be hanging but
everybody nineteen eleven benji should push
the boat well you see he's got checkmate
he has to push and he's got checkmate into
you but he's not like two seconds because rook
takes okay all right yeah now let's check me ten
seconds nine eight he didn't play in the painting
no he's gonna i think daniel's gonna flag that
oh my god he has five seconds seconds four just
moved that's what he's doing oh oh my goodness he
wow i was getting so close i timed out ben jesus
1.2 seconds moving right away ah he deserves it
anyway but i don't know how the heck that happened
wow sick one sick one what a game wow
clutch win by banjo fishy he had the upper hand
and he had checkmate if we just roll back to that
moment i thought banjo was calculating that he
had that palm push and he was one move away from
checkmate you promote a8 and that guards the rook
maybe he was worried that the rook was hanging
he didn't push he wasn't checkmate and then he
had one second left it was definitely everything
sure definitely the time pressure but
he did it and i mean not having a lot
of experience and without increment but
he saved it right in time and was such
absolute gentleman we're going to be
talking to the players in a moment
this was our second quarter finals of the day
benjamin fishy qualifying to the semi-finals
daniel negron who won the first game
but then benji came back in the second
rapid game and won this final sudden
death blitz game we're gonna go for a
short break and then we are back with the
players boxing three presented by grif6
he choked so bad he choked but
he still managed to win the game
the bullet training came to the rescue and with
one second remaining oh my gosh if benji made
his move in time the granu had 0.1 seconds left
the granu if benji had failed to make his move
would have won with .1 seconds uh but but he made
it he made it and the crown who loses on time and
benji's through to the semi-final oh my oh wow
pickle thank you so much for the five dollar dono
oh gosh i am very happy we practiced one minute
games i was having so much fun when we did the
five minute games because i thought it was so
fun to to to do commentary on benji playing one
minute benji didn't like it benji doesn't
like being low on time it stresses him out
but i'm very glad we practiced that situation
coming in with the five gifted subs thank you
so much bola also coming in with the gifted subs
it's two to high coming in with the five gifted
oh my gosh an islumo coming in with
100 bits bola mvp no today the mvp
is benji clutching it up in literally the last
second of the match he comes in with the clutch
uh also oh my bad i i needed to make a new
board so my alerts haven't been showing up
i cannot get better than that i don't think it
can i don't think it can get better than that but
benji let's be honest that blitz game he nailed
it he nailed it he played that blitz game so well
benji just he dominated from start to finish and
he was finding all the double attacks yes he he
almost messed it up because he gets a low on time
he doesn't like to get low on time but throughout
that game he dominated and overall i think he's
a deserved winner of this uh this quarterfinal
this is the most exciting chess i've ever seen
well i'm glad you enjoyed it viper stick around
for more exciting chess because the semi-final
might get even better uh uh um benji will play the
winner uh between uh rayne wilson and um and the
ludwig so benji has qualified to the semi-finals
and he's going to get a tough game
there as well thank you kai for the sub
thank you kai a rain wilson or moist okay my bad
i it it's gonna be rain wilson let's be
honest it's gonna be rain wilson in the
welcome back to the broadcast of park
chambers three presented by grip six we
are being joined by benjamin fische and daniel
negrano benji daniel what a match this has been
yeah it was pretty close uh looking like a bit
closer than uh especially that last game uh yeah
that one second left was that i didn't even
realize i only had one second i'm not gonna
lie i got a little bit lucky but you know happier
happy i won by timeout i guess daniel should have
prepared the dirty flagging techniques at the end
there taking your queen could have tried something
tricky you know you're right actually that's
like i should have strategized for that because
when i had two seconds left i'm like wait a minute
how am i out because i forgot while i was playing
that there's no increments because i was like
oh don't worry you play fast you're good so when
i was down four points with like 30 40 seconds
left the strategy should have been to just start
taking everything and trade trade trade and then
try to like you know win the the cheesy way win
by time yeah i mean that's all bullet chests man
it doesn't matter how bad you're losing you hang
on till the end and you try to get any flag you
can yeah that's the way you learn lesson learned
like yeah cause like even when you're in a losing
position uh with with the time factor especially
short for i know i don't know if benji plays a lot
of five minute games but significant difference
between 10 and increment and five in terms of how
quickly you got to make moves benji your coach was
saying that you don't play much blitz chess how
did you feel about playing this tiebreaker are we
going to go back to the rapid games as well but
just the fact that you had to play a tiebreaker
daniel i think you have quite some experience in
blitz chess i have seen over 900 games in blitz
on your account but maybe most of them are with
increment do you prefer playing with increment
well i think a lot of those blitz games happen
before it switched to rapid or i don't know
because i always played 10-minute games and i only
i don't i didn't play 900 that are less than 10
for sure i like the increment aspect because like
you know at least when you're down to a minute
you know you're not just completely dead you know
you get that back i love the idea so much frankly
that i want to start integrating that into poker
tournaments because i think it would really be
helpful to uh speed things up and make it really
exciting as we had here with the the tiebreak
match that came down to one second too bad he
didn't notice maybe he took another second i
would have won by time crazy so close so close it
was really close benji your thoughts on that final
moment you said that you realized later that you
did have checkmate in one and that maybe in that
case your coach wouldn't have had a heart attack
when you had only one second left with a queen up
uh yeah i realized right after that i when i
checked with the brook that i could have checked
mate and wanted him uh but you know i i i did
realize that i was like pretty low on time so i
just started rushing my moves uh and if you could
show that position that moment revenge is saying
uh when he had the promotion yeah you were
very low on time dania all credits to you
by the way though because you were low on time
and you were down a piece so you almost made a
miracle happen by coming back on both like you
escaped with your king when the king was gonna
be checkmated and you also managed to to cut down
on time because benji was ahead on time for most
of the game yeah no i mean listen he's he he's he
played really really well and you know when you're
playing with short time and you're a beginner
like me or you know at our level like you're
just going to make mistakes when you're rushed
right and that's okay um the one that i wasn't
rushed on the big mistake was in game two where i
moved the wrong rook to block the the queen check
and i blundered and i let him do that what do you
call that you call that the botez gambit i just
i actually didn't see it either i saw a five
and i thought about it and i was like why is
this losing and then i i saw at the same time
you did so yeah i didn't see it i was too
preoccupied with like you know my attack that's
one of those mistakes i'm making chess is like
oh you get like you know one tunnel vision in your
attack and you're like oops you know you don't
just donate the queen and then as hannah says
like it happened to me again after i gave away
the queen i mean i could just take his bishop and
i'm like nope i don't want it now you keep it yeah
sometimes it happens that then you make another
mistake because you're you're i think you were
talking about it on your stream that it happens
and poker 2 when when you get tilted for a moment
and then it can affect the next decision too but
you you thought you both fought so well if we go
back to to this rook d4 move in game two up until
that moment we thought daniel that you did have
quite some compensation for the pawn because uh
i feel like you do like these type of positions
where even though your opponent can have one
or two extra pawns you have initiative you're
going with these aggressive attacking moves and
if it wasn't for this tactical motif let's say
king to h1 or rook f2 you you have quite a lot
of initiative for the pawn and for banjo it's
not easy to develop the c8 bishop that's always
the sad piece in the french defense unfortunately
but benji you do love your french defense and you
you came back in a situation where you had to win
you had to win this game in order to earn
a tiebreaker um if we also discuss some
of the details from game one by the way and
drive if you haven't i'm here i am right here
i don't know where the bullet went but i have
this one sure no worries daniel your thoughts on
game one the game you won and how you felt about
that bishop winning the rook so after e5 you were
thinking of this ampersand so you did all this on
purpose and it i think it was a great idea to free
your pieces you took back on e6 with the rook and
then benji pushed e4 i was saying to andra i think
banji wants to set up this bishop h3 tactics
it's a very sneaky one it's really sneaky to
spot it and it eventually happened the move later
that he managed to win your rook so it wasn't uh
spotted but you recovered so well you recovered
right after because white is an exchange up but
i thought you came up with some really really
creative ideas moving the king away opening up
the g5 if you see our board daniel um here with
the attack on the g5 bringing the queen to g4
it was an incredible comeback from a moment of
of blundering your rogue blundering the exchange
and then you took the initiative and it's it's
banji who has to be really careful here yeah so
that that was interesting because i did not see
it as you said i was like again tunnel visioned
on that bishop because my guy dave odyssey who's
a chess player in edmonton who prepped me he uh he
told me that benji often will move that bishop
in front of his king and he shouldn't but he's
willing to trade it often so i was like trying
to trade the bishops and open up that like spot
there um but then when i on the in the other game
when i was was i would when i was playing white
he literally gave me every single move benji was
going to make up till like you know when the the
the exchange of the bishop for the the the knight
in that game like every single move and he like
he did all the prep and show me the benji loses
here 56 of the time so when he did it i was like
oh my god i got him right but then of course
i made the mistake you know with the rook but
i was definitely happy with being able to sort of
play a sicilian type game with black because i'm
way more comfortable with that he doesn't let me
go up the right side and just do my thing but i
was able to still develop the position i learned
an indian just in case he moved d4 i was gonna do
that so that's why i moved the the knight first i
did a lot of new things that i don't typically do
and i learned so much with this whole process
about how chess works and how the bluffing aspect
there's so much bluffing because like a guy's
gonna like oh you think i'm gonna do this and
then i come up with this totally new open you've
never seen i was gonna use the ponziani if need be
because i had that in my pocket i was gonna throw
that one out later but i didn't practice it enough
besides he plays the french anyway and uh yeah i
mean it's been a great process i'm you know proud
of you benji you played really really well and i
wish you luck in the next round thank you i have
one more question for daniel i thought of this
so do you like gambits because you like gambling
a little bit right i like gambits because
i listen i like fun unique different things
what i've learned you know unfortunately is
prepping gambits for a tournament is a bad idea
because when a player knows they're going to
be playing against you all the data well i
didn't realize because one of the things that
poker players are good at is parsing data all
the data available on chess.com like my guy dove
in with using the explorer figuring out all of
benji's plays right like i said i was like shocked
he's like you're gonna get this exact position
and benji loses from here and i'm like how this
is so cool so i love that aspect of it but i've
learned to sort of like retire the gambits again
in tournaments for for the time being and you know
use them when i play recreational because like
when i learned the england gambit from uh from uh
lee levi or levy sorry you know it worked
on everybody i was like beating everyone
unfortunately when pokemony prepared for it
it just you know you just eat dust it's like
it's no good so um gotta learn how to play
chess properly and play the gambits for fun
tournament situation certainly but you you came
very well prepared for today so dania you have
a better coach than levy or me or hikaru you have
definitely prepared very well and benji kudos to
you for how far you have come you are moving
on to the semi-finals what do you think will
happen in the other clash you will play either
against rayne wilson or against moyes critical
your thoughts on that quarterfinal match uh i'm i
think i'm gonna be fine for i think i'm just gonna
keep practicing you know do do the usual keep
what keep doing what i've been doing practicing
with hammer um and i think i think hopefully i'll
be all right and i'll be able to get to the finals
yeah i mean you and hammer dream team man because
i didn't was saying i was coach did that strategy
but i bet hammer was doing the same thing because
i've seen him prepared yeah they were one step
ahead of you daniel well actually i thought
i was doing good after the opening it's just
that he's better he was he was better after that
like you know i thought i got good positions so
yeah i certainly agree absolutely i thought
the preparation was great on both sides
we were saying with android it felt like we
were watching a high high level chess grand
monster games because you were blitzing at theory
until move 10 and very very classical setups from
both sides especially that french defense
game felt like you're you're professional
chess players not professional poker
and fortnite players in this case
daniel absolutely daniel we hope to see
you be back at pogchamps 4 because you're
more than ready to take on these challenges so we
hope to see you at the future chess event as well
i love the process like i said i put a lot of
time into it unfortunately wasn't good enough
in the end but i was ultimately i was proud of
how i played today i was really disappointed how
i played against xqc i was just my brain was not
working that day but today i thought i played as
well as i could for my level and uh i hope to
be back for pogchamps 4. amazing that would be
amazing to see and we will be rooting for benji
now that he's moving on to the semifinals thank
you so much for joining us and all the best
for the rest benji thank you guys very much
that has been it benji fishy moving on to the
semi-finals and he will be facing either rain
wilson or moist critical andra your thoughts
on that quarterfinal because benji was very
diplomatic he didn't pick yeah well he said
he was pretty confident but rain if it is i
i my guess is gonna be rain versus benji and i'm
terrified of rain that man is so strong i must say
so that'll be a great matchup i think in that
case i'm going to pick charlie because he has
been preparing with dania with daniel he's got
the support of his dog as well who often times
jumps in through the game so that's gonna
be certainly a tough one and we will know
it soon because tomorrow that clash will be the
first one to start the broadcast rayne wilson
versus moyes critical take a look at the times
ladies and gentlemen because we're going to have
four matches starting at 10 30 pacific rain wilson
against moist critical then nico versus rubius
my heart will be absolutely torn as usual when
my students are facing each other but they are
the quarterfinals clash in the consolation bracket
championship break it down between ludwig and
logic one of them will move on to the semi-finals
the other one will have to say goodbye to the
event unfortunately as it is in knockout and
the final match will be between pokeman and myth
they know each other very well but i think this
is gonna be the first time they face each other at
chess that is very true they've never played other
games but there are so many matchups tomorrow big
decisions i mean you lose the championship
you're out so we'll see who's gonna make it
it's gonna be a very exciting day andrea thank
you so much for handling so well the tech part you
were you were the producer of the show it came to
the board and you did very good very good job for
your first time yeah i'm so glad everyone knows
that all the times the board was lagging it was me
you did amazing if it was me i would have been
loading all sorts of other browsers clicking
here and there so you did a lot better than what
my boomer skills are capable of but we want to
thank andrea for being here papa botez for rooting
for for daniel now we know canadian romanian yes
thank you anna for for carrying and yeah the
tech part we'll get better at that you know
with as with the years to come we hopefully have
years to come for park champs as well because
this is a brilliant event and a reminder that
we will be back tomorrow maybe not us but the
show will be back tomorrow thank you so much for
tuning in thank you so much for watching better
tech more smooth boards chat don't you worry
maybe smoother boards but not smoother brains
because you guys have done an amazing job in the
chat with all sorts of ideas and strategies coming
up always for the players thank you so much for
following the show remember that you can still
donate every single day we are fundraising
for the 16 charities that the participants
have chosen so the banner is below the video you
can also use exclamation mark donating the chat
click on the link and donate chess.com we'll be
matching your donations up to a hundred thousand
dollars so make sure to let shares of campaign
loads for charity because it's a great cause
16 charities that will be benefiting from them
and on that note andrea final words final sign off
um i don't have any final words very bad on
the spot except that tomorrow's gonna be a
very exciting day we got four big matches lots
of students that i'm rooting for so how about you
thank you for being here and germany definitely
need more bonus gambits in our lives and
our tax kits will improve one day
thank you so much again everybody
now
oh
all the way all the way down
so
foreign